and we are live welcome to the last word
episode number 120 and it's another
glorious friday we're back from the
campfire for some more lunar shooter
discussion
i'm extremely excited about our two
amazing ladies and dynamic pvp special
guests
so e i'm gonna need you to get right to
it
one of these ladies started out having
to duke it out with her brothers just to
get time to game so it would be fitting
she enjoyed
other ladies kicking butt like lara
croft and buffy between fallout
elder scrolls and neverwinter this lady
has embraced the rpgs over the years
but don't let her humble origins put you
at ease because trust me
she will school you in more ways than
gaming this woman has put in the work in
the gym and on the pavement
and fitness is now a big part of her
life but she still knows that pineapple
is okay on pizza in a spicy chick-fil-a
sandwich
is alright every now and then her skills
though in crucible
are high to say the least and her snipes
will leave your eyes wide and your jaw
on the floor
don't challenge this girl to a 1v1
because in the end she's gonna clutch up
crush your dreams and have you give a
rain check on that wager
cognito and of course the second lady we
have joining us is the master of
analyzing your every word and move
with a degree in psychology to prove it
her gaming history goes all the way back
to the og days of nintendo ds where
mario will always be a friend in our
heart
whether it's playing fable assassin's
creed or halo these classics will always
top her all-time gaming charts
and with her smooth jams playing and
super chill pvp
streams don't get it twisted she could
still pop your head off with sunspots
and thorn dots
both of these ladies started their
destiny journeys on the path of the
hunter so of course they would be strong
in the ways of the crucible and now they
have made a place for even more awesome
ladies in the destiny community to come
together
and grow as friends players and
teammates one helps take care of animals
the other has four babies of her own one
has is a fan of foxes and the other's
name is actually that of a female
fox so without further ado let's welcome
the two
and and amazing co-founders of scrim
queens to the campfire vixen and
foxytocin welcome
welcome to episode 120 how you guys
doing
good i didn't know we were getting
official intro
i'm not prepared for this we
have to do it you gotta do it you're at
the campfire you're on guess
what's good good it's going good just
chilling excited to be here excited to
talk some pvp
oh yes nice nice and vixen how are we
doing
i'm doing great glad to be off work and
glad it's a friday
sneaking home from work running here to
get to the podcast we appreciate that
makes squeezing us into your schedule
um absolutely so i know i said it
earlier
but first question random um just
because i already got asked on twitter
as well
pineapple on pizza is this a yay or nay
yeah yes yes
we got both yeses on pineapple there we
go
one thing of agreement when we get
started this is amazing because yeah
definitely
you have pineapples you allowed is that
is that condiment allowed for you
because you know
like that's not even remotely a condom
and it's a first dude
you're not like things you don't like
peter this is a whole deal
but i want to start now now let's go we
don't need to start with food
so anyway i just had to get that one
pineapple on pizza is safe i also saw
the spicy chick-fil-a sandwich i'm like
i
completely approved that they they
nailed the spicy sandwich so
yeah that was good for the frozen
lemonade
did you see that video where they showed
how much sugar goes on it's ridiculous
but the main reason that we brought you
guys on tonight is um
obviously you guys are amazing uh ladies
just cool each other on twitch channels
and everything
but you guys started scream queens which
is a really cool pvp community
for ladies uh guys are welcome in the
community as well but specifically there
are
you know ladies tournaments and you guys
bring them in you do education things
like that so
kind of wanted to give a little history
of how you guys brought scrum cranes
into the destiny community and just kind
of what your goals were for it
floor is yours tell us all about it and
what you guys are doing either of you or
both or trade off tag team however you
want to do it
um well i guess i mean i can i can go
because i i
came to foxy with the idea um
and my my idea personally stemmed from
back in what was it june when all of
that stuff was coming out
about certain people in the community
and um i personally just wanted
i think after that happened we had a
ladies night
um and i was like this is something that
i kind of want to put together to bring
ladies together and so i brought the
idea to fox
and here we are
so how did you get oh go ahead no i was
just gonna say how did you guys settle
on the name and
what what was on the chalkboard that got
crossed off
i kind of want to know what didn't make
it there were two names
yeah oh yeah it was
i think i came up with ladies scrim hub
or something or ladies competitive hub
something along those lines um i just
didn't want it to sound inappropriate
because um many many reasons
uh there's something i think it's like
sweat hub or something like that and i
think it can't be ladies sweatshop
that's inappropriate yeah you want to
avoid that type of stuff i think for
what you guys are going for
yeah and so uh then fox came out of
nowhere with scrim queens
it was over i like it yeah it's it fits
yeah it's it's really cool i think for
me the question i had was like
you know as a fan of of pvp like i love
that you two
represent that community really go hard
at it so like
you know as far as we we know there's
things going on in the pvp scene but
like what's making you guys
stick with it why you still have the
passion both of you
for for either you know sweat so
competitive pvp just pvp in general
um i think for
me i've always been like unnecessarily
competitive in some situations
so um a chance to
like do that in a video game i've never
gotten to do that before like the
closest i got was playing private
matches in halo with my brother
and i didn't even know there was like an
mlg scene for halo
or i probably would have been like a
whole different child but
um as soon as i learned there was like
somewhat of a competitive scene for
destiny even if it's not pro or whatever
that's a whole different argument
um right i wanted to be involved with it
and the more i got involved with it i
just realized there were no other girls
in it
um like almost at all and the more
like when stuff started coming out about
the destiny communion stuff i was just
like oh well this is kind of why like it
doesn't surprise me now
um so when vixen came to me with an idea
to get something going to get more
ladies involved i was like
i get to improve they get to improve
like it's a win-win like i want to help
as many people as i can
if they want to be involved in the scene
if they're passionate about it
um why not give them that opportunity
and like playing that stuff is what has
kept me involved in pvp if i just played
matchmade activities i probably wouldn't
play
anymore but doing pickups and tourneys
recently stuff like that
that's definitely held my passion for
the game so
that's awesome that's awesome you know
vixen as far as you like pvp like
you know most most i would say you know
destiny kind of leans toward a little
bit more pve heavy so
to see you guys kind of like it's just a
little bit you know keep kind of like
flag keep the flag high in reference to
it and
like what what keeps you passionate
about playing pvp
so destiny well destiny
as a whole is my first pvp shooter um
i did not come from cod or des or sorry
um halo anything like that um so
it's always just been um
initially it was just getting into it
and now it's just been trying to improve
as much as i can as
as it goes as much as she can do not
challenge her to at 1v1
i see some snipes see some streams he's
looking real serious i love
the pin tweet i i yeah that is that was
like
we're going down no we have to go there
because i
want just like shorts it doesn't have to
be an in-depth story
but i want anybody who listens to this
to hear about this because i
covered it real quickly in the
introduction but tell us the story of
that pin tweet because it has to because
just looking at a loan is great
um so if i remember correctly um
so that came from a dating app um and
on there it says something along the
lines of i don't even
have it anymore but um that i like to
play video games
or i like to play fps shooters and the
first like that's the kind of response
i get all the time is like oh fortnite
or 1v1
and so finally i got sick of it i was
like okay well
here we go and um
we we got into a private match and the
entire
time he was complaining about his lag
oh my he was complaining that like uh
his shot wasn't right
like i know his shot wasn't right he
tried the shooting
play whatever you want so he ended up
starting out with an ace of spade and
then changed
to a
[Laughter]
vigilance wing he did not put on the
v-wing
that's not even the full amount that he
got like
uh he actually got three instead of
five because i let him kill me twice to
to
test lag so that was like oh wait hold
on
hold on vicks vixx is assassinated she's
like hold on so your legs best all right
let me let you get
let me get you optimal and then i can
continue to keep on beating you down
salute like no we're going to keep it
fair i'm going to show you
with optimal settings you're still going
to get this work like i will stand still
let's test the fire fire speed okay wow
what was that what was the final tally
on that one again it
was like 27 to 57 to five
yeah just an absolute beating i don't
know if
am i allowed to cuss on here
so the game ended and it was silent and
shocking i was like um so what now
was it what do you mean i was like are
you gonna [ __ ] off
yeah i was like all right bye and i hung
up the call
oh that's amazing oh many many a shot
was lost
i just love that though because like
i mean guys guys never expected no no i
was just gonna say guys never expected
the fact that you put him in that place
this much i'm so happy you did
that was my plan i mean if he would have
won i would have stuck to my word
oh you would have went to okay respect
respect just because i'm a person of my
word but
i i had a bit of confidence i was like
listen i just want to put this person in
their place because i'm sick of the 1v1s
all i ever get
you just need that picture now anybody
on the dating app just sends it to you
just like here's my tweet
exactly are you sure you still want to
do sure you won't do this
that's funny foxy do you encounter any
uh similar type of uh
interactions on uh social media
in reference to dc oh
gosh i've had a lot of weird
interactions
let's get it let's get uncomfortable
with guys on social media
the most recent one actually was in
regards to me and
my fiance luna and it was very awkward
yes yeah i was so i was so weirded out
yeah which i call it thornhub it was
like thorn after darkness so something
was going on
yeah i was like wow what it does like
but now i need to know more please
explain tell the story tell us
so um well first of all for reference
like in the comments section
our discord that that we run together is
called thornhab
and that's where our clan runs pickups
out of and stuff
it's totally just a meme because thorn
was our favorite weapon and we just
figured
why the hell not absolutely but
i actually got an instagram dm which is
weird because i don't even really post
pictures of him and i on instagram like
there are probably more pictures of us
together on twitter
right and it was something along the
lines of like i i'm like
jealous of you and luna like you guys
look so good together i can't imagine
how hot you are in bed together and i
was like oh
hey hey extra
vixen was worried about custom but we
just crossed over to after dark too
it's a late night campfire y'all
i don't know what you're drinking it may
need to get a little spicier tonight
though
continue continue that's friday night i
was
so confused i was like okay
that's what's going on twitter
yo uncle notice and flying on the plane
is a family-friendly shot
the fire is on fire
no no no no this is this is what
unfortunately is like one of those
things it's like
the people living behind the veil of the
internet and the crap that they will do
especially as a male we get like one
percent of it
yeah of just like some stupid people and
unfortunately
for the ladies who are all out there you
guys get much much more of it so
um for one you guys have to have a thick
skin
just in general just even be like on
twitch streaming be in there for one
moderators are a lifesaver so hopefully
i know you guys have good ones of those
but it's just like
um for you guys to
random stupid stories either guys trying
to date and do stupid 1v1s or really
awkward things between you and your
fiance when they know you're engaged
like
is there anything you guys can say to
any of the ladies out there that
mentioned that
helps you either get past or ignore or
just kind of push past those weird
situations any
advice that you've got out there just
for any other ladies that may be even
scared to be like i'm afraid to turn on
my camera because of
the blank point
um big ask
no you're good um something that
genuinely
like helps me and i know everyone is
different
but like making a meme out of it
actually helps me because
i get to share it with other people who
like
i consider acquaintances and also just
new people i meet on the internet
um and like seeing all those funny
comments underneath that weird
instagram dm for example like it just
lightens the mood around it
and i'm like i i can't take it seriously
anymore you know like it
wasn't a big deal it wasn't something
that bothered me in the first place like
i can really only think of one comment
that ever bothered me that i've gotten
in my twitch chat
and it i literally remember seeing it
pop up and it was gone before i could
even finish reading the sentence and the
only reason i knew what it was is
because the person had deemed it to me
on twitter also
wow but i get other than that
like i don't know like just having good
mods in like a good circle because the
majority of the comments that pop into
my chat i don't even see them by the
time i look over
and like it just completely it takes so
much stress off my shoulders i don't
even have to worry about it
not importance of mods that's a that's a
great point so that it doesn't even hit
you hit your radar what about you uh fix
it like any
advice you would give out there for uh
aspiring ladies to uh
streaming and stuff so i actually just
started using a facecam
um probably what like two months maybe a
month ago
and um my
personal feeling
or whatever it's called happy people
don't try to make other people
unhappy so that's just what i keep in my
mind
like if someone's happy they're not
going to try to break someone else down
so something's wrong with that person
that's my mantra free preach it's it's
too much
uh i feel like especially on social
media like everyone like
complains like everyone's so you can't
be that miserable
like you don't say like i just feel like
some people are very extreme like
extremely negative and then that kind of
seeps into a lot and it's just like look
we're playing games we're supposed to be
having fun
you know and i agree i i do feel it's on
that person
when you know that person is you know
consistently negative and bringing that
energy
there's something else going on in my
opinion
with that person because look at the
internet i mean it's not the greatest
but
you know these are video games we're
supposed to have fun this is a community
you know there shouldn't be any room for
all that constant negativity so i i
agree with that
statement nice very large
very large pooch uh cameo there in the
background
not alone does she have fiance and guard
dog so yeah don't don't mess with her
yes
exactly uh a couple rapid fire questions
i wanted to ask
um favorite cereal
cinnamon toast crunch yes sorry
that's mine too so gotta have a little
salute
um i've been oh my god i've been on a
completely different diet for a year now
yeah i haven't had cereal in a year well
okay we'll get to that part but it's
like
used to be then oh god
oh god uh fruit loops i couldn't think
that's solid choice um
and then for you guys uh if you're gonna
have
of the two of you if one has to take a
sniper shot one has to use a shotgun
shot who's gonna take it
oh i'm definitely letting vixen have
sniper i'm a terrible sniper i will ape
all day long that's fine with me
nice uh and then favorite workout
work workout workout or just like
favorite exercise you do i love running
okay
probably yoga for me nice
i need the i need the mental calm my
mind
runs in enough circles i need something
to slow it down fair enough
no doubt i was gonna ask unless she
still got wrapped
up you're good no that was just a couple
of quick ones now i was gonna have some
little fun meta questions like as far as
like
loadouts what's the some loadouts right
now that you're just in along with
thorne
[Laughter]
i mean i personally i either change it
up between
dire promise and rose or um
diary promise and rose and then um
beloved or
all winters i guess i'm not a huge fan
of fell wonders though
so there's some there's some ape going
on over there on occasions occasionally
oh my sniper is kind of a shotgun too
yeah almost like that it's like just
beloved
um scary sniper by the way scary sniper
uh don't push me with a sniper okay it's
like that
no they don't push don't push
[ __ ] you but about you so i i heard thor
obviously but
uh that that's a mainstay or just like
does anything deviate from that out of
that
um yeah i'm i mean i'll use like pretty
much any handkin
i really like lumina um oh i like very
underrated
yeah lumina is a lot of fun um and then
of course i'll use like dire spare or
something like that but thorn and
luminer are probably like my two
favorite hand cannons
um i loved ace before they
[ __ ] on 140s but rest in peace
i know i know let me ask you this about
i got to ask you a little bit because i
love hearing that you use luna
like are you also using the
team healing abilities in conjunction
once you get kills
yeah 100 the team healing and the like
uh
damage buff especially in pickups can be
like and with the catalyst now because
you get two words
both your teammates yeah it's kind of
wild i i
love like once i got the catalyst i
really fell in love with it
and i know you don't work out hunters
yeah as a warlock i really embraced like
a
a support build like just really helping
out so for me i'm
like i'm making religion like who needs
blessings who needs who they i'm just
like giving them out like
that thing has aggressive tracking like
luminous um
like you can really like really heal
someone from far and it'll aggressively
track and attach itself
to another person on your teammate so
it's a very underrated build so i
respect on that one i like that
it was like i feel like we said our
generally
favorite class for you guys i know you i
know
foxy you kind of switch but if you had
to pick one what would you pick
oh gosh
gun to your head probably bottom tree
hammers honestly i
like it's the thing i've enjoyed the
most most recently it's so much fun
whether it's in pickups or
just in quick play like uh sun sponsored
so enjoyable
nice fellow titan there we go yeah i've
actually had a lot of fun with bottom
tree
not to the pvp level but i just still
love using it in a lot of things and
that new exotic made it a lot more
viable too
vixen vixen
um i used to be for two years
um a bottom tree arcstrider main but
i've been trying out
spectral which i'm forming a love hate
relationship with hit registration again
um
and now i'm trying out blade barrage to
be more flexible
as i tried warlock and scrims and i felt
like i was suffocating
i love that description thank you that's
lying
i felt like i was suffocating oh my god
every time i tried to shade stuff i was
throwing down i was literally
a sitting target
she's like
the floof isn't for everyone yeah
we got some so we got luna and heather
bothly saying floof is best over there
they love the flames
sorry heather is a crazy warlock maine
[Music]
yeah um but for you guys like uh when
you guys put together the turn the
kind of your scrims and stuff like that
in pickups are you guys fairly flexible
do you try and
like vixen you sound like your sniper
all day long
per se um when you guys put together
how many are in your kind of typical
pickup teams and what is just a pickup
for you guys look like within
scream queens
um it kind of varies but we
we typically have like eight teams about
like 24 girls with a lot of subs too
um and we actually
work together to build the teams um
depending on
free time and it's
it's a lot that goes into it i don't
think people realize how much goes into
it
but um i try to at least
from my own perspective i try to pair up
people that i feel like would be
flexible together but whatever works
works
yeah we we usually try to do like a
healthy balance of
hey we want the teams to be balanced
when they're playing each other we don't
want
anyone like just getting rolled or
rolling the other
team because that doesn't encourage
improvement for either team
right um so we try to balance them skill
wise and then we also try to
you know learn a little bit about the
girls throughout the weeks and then
we want them to like push themselves and
play other characters and try
like you know if someone's really
comfortable on sniper maybe try
shoddying that week or vice versa but we
also don't want them to be
in that situation every single week
right so we kind of tried to balance
those things out and it's like a healthy
mix of
try something new but also we want you
to have fun and be comfortable so
i was gonna ask you that because in
reference to like you know as far as the
skill gaps and things of that nature
like how you guys work on
maybe encouraging a girl who's maybe
she's struggling and not having
the greatest time you know or just not
feeling like she's really helping out
the team like
what kind of strats or encouragement
tactics you guys use to kind of
get people's kind of confidence up
um i don't i don't i have like most
recent experience like my last
um set um
i was talked to and said like i don't
really know much about scrims i don't
really know call outs i don't know
the set in the other and um personally i
just tried to take extra care to like
explain situations or explain why i'm
doing what i'm doing or why we're going
this way or why
i just try to take that extra little
step to make sure i'm being very vocal
gotcha yep kind of almost talking them
through like a raid encounter but like
the way you'd
handle a pvp might be like instead of
this is how this bus works be like
i'm heading over here for this reason
because they could be coming here's your
possible sight lines
that type of nice well
i got a funny question what about the
opposite what do you encounter like uh
someone who who claims like they they
they know what they're doing
and you know maybe directing things
every guy ever yeah yeah and not really
successful like how do you deal with
that strong-headed person that might not
necessarily be doing the right things
but thinks
they are doing the right things yo fox
how do you handle me when i switch to
shotgun because i'm very
dummy stupid like i'm so aggressive can
you just put that sniper back on things
i i do i wouldn't say we actually really
or i haven't encountered
any of the girls like that at all no one
has actually overconfident like there
are definitely some girls who are more
confident in their abilities but none of
them are
like overly confident to the point where
it's inaccurate
um but if they are in that case i just
put them in the lobby like with some of
the best girls and if they keep up they
keep up then they can keep their
confidence and if they don't then maybe
it will humble them a little like
that's just kind of how pickups work you
know like but i've seen that happen
like so many times and um like with any
with any gender like with guys or
whatever like guys will come join our
pickups and they'll get rolled by
someone in the lobby and they're like oh
crap
uh i need to win that person for the
next month like you know what i mean
so um yeah we just kind of do that and i
i've also like i try to always tell
people to like
say like vixen just said when i switched
to shoddy like
i just try like if you're being over
aggressive it's just like let's try to
team shot a little bit more or if
they're not team shying enough like it's
kind of the same call out because
it's honestly really difficult to be
completely useless in pickups because
there's so many roles you can fill
as a teammate like that's cool you can
be encouraging
you can give really good call outs your
team shots could be nuts you could be
outslaying everyone like
there are so many different ways for you
to help a team so
like encouraging them in those different
ways so that they feel like they're
feeling like filling a role
is good because as soon as they have
that confidence that they're filling one
role then they start to push for another
you know so
that's kind of the key to it in my
opinion but
yeah that's cool i agree
with that i just wanted to the
i i personally tried to win
i see things i try to complement it
constantly so it
builds that confidence so they feel like
they're a part of it
absolutely random quick question what is
the little black thing hanging from your
mic and does it have a name
oh goodness i was asked this probably
like two other podcasts
it's it's like i can't not see it so i
have to ask about it
so this is the monster from spirited
away they're like
oh sorry the sprite monsters so that's
great here we go
he does not have a name um
he's still two podcasts later and he
still doesn't have a name
[Laughter]
uh and then second question what's up
with staples oh god
oh god you can thank somebody in chat
for that one i
forget who who asked heather
she knows okay yep that is a quick
thrown under the bus
thank you heather is this a story you
don't have to tell if you don't want to
but
now we we are interesting so this goes
back to the whole
um awkward situations we've had um
with males but um
so i was in the oh my god i'm sorry you
might hear my dogs losing it
yeah oh that's fine my wolves will hell
in the background too it's okay
um so i was in the the
market for a chair and i heard that
staples was having like a summer
in clearance sale or something like that
and they had the chair that i was
looking for
so i drove all the way to uh staples
i don't know if i said target staples
and um
someone help me out help me put my thing
in the car
asked me what i do i said twitch i
didn't give my twitch name out
nothing like that i paid with my paypal
card that
has my twitch name on it and uh
got home and this person had found my
twitch
and found my message me on inside sorry
messaged me on
discord and said something along the
lines of
hey i helped you at staples and
mm-hmm he was just creepy wow
boundaries boundaries come on
wow okay unbelievable
people people get a little a little
thirsty you have to
have to relax yeah so one random story
going around twitter too and it's just
like
there's this streamer girl i really like
her i want to ask her on the date like
the obvious answer was just like
that just don't that's that's not how
that's going to just don't just
just is that the one where he's like
should i get a job where she goes to
god yeah i don't know like she goes to
this gym or
like some place and yeah or whatever it
was and should i get a job
i'm like no boundaries gentlemen oh my
dreams
yeah stalk much yeah
seriously damn yeah that's ridiculous
right look i i get it you know crushes
and all that stuff but you we got to
respect the ladies
come on now like either shoot your shot
in person and
if you don't worry that's it but i'm
going to do all that stuff
person at staples wasn't even a person
that i interacted with it was someone i
guess who was
watching me from afar and got my twitch
information from
or the information from someone else and
contacted me on discord
there's another level on to just keep
throwing it on
just pile it on
thanks baloz
you gotta take a page out of the decency
book read it once a day
it's not it's i see random things on
twitter it's like it's not that hard to
be a decent person
and it seems like it shouldn't be but it
continues to prove it so that's always
so weird
yeah i got one last question well once
we get out the yike zone
um like that [ __ ] was actually
trials you know i'm i'm a huge trials
fan
i love the ladies pvp but i want to know
like how you guys feel about it
do you still play it obviously we know
the cheating situation let's go out on
vc but
how are we feeling about trials you know
and then also moving forward with trials
anybody oh
i i'm i feel bad
starting since you love trials i always
go about talking to people and they're
like i love trials and i'm just like
yeah i
hate it it's okay it's okay
all opinions are welcome here in destiny
with
all the different type of space magic
and guns they have
i just don't enjoy single life game
modes um
i don't enjoy it right now either i
guess like obviously just a bad taste in
my mouth because i never played trials
in d1
so i didn't have that nostalgia at all
got you okay so
my first experience with it was beaver
codes and cheaters
like shout out to the beatles
so from then on and not only that but
just like the loot incentive and stuff
was just not
not enough for me because i would rather
and i'm a like from a pvp person talking
i would rather go grind nightfalls with
a team
than go through trials to get the same
loot you know
so i think i played it for like a month
every weekend just to get the armor sets
on
all three of my characters and that was
it i really haven't touched it since
then gotcha i'm fair enough
and you made a good point like if you
don't have that nostalgia attachment to
it as well and then your first
experience is all these beavers and then
cheating and stuff like that you know i
completely understand oh
fix any any trials love or the same not
not really a trials person
so uh i actually came into the twitch
community through
destiny one child's carries um and i was
a part of the
trials carries community for the
entirety of d1
and then i actually did trials help
um d2 um
coming back into d2 at forsaken and then
when trials finally came back i have a
love-hate relationship with it
now as many do actually i don't even
know if there's really love there but
um um i play it
i've been playing it more every weekend
i'm trying to get back into use to the
swing of
single life gameplay because i am a
sixes
uh soloer and
it's it's yeah uh charles is fun please
auntie cheat bungie yes yes
[Music]
can i get some uh favorite trials
weapons any any any standouts for you
that
did you remember lord uh
all i remember is that what was that the
doctrine of passing
made me cry i hated it
did you get that persistence roll what
was it all i don't know
there was so many good roles but that
that gun it was it was a
laser beam yes it was it's it feels like
we're reliving it right now not knowing
hunger all over again just a
a little slower but still just about as
deadly yeah 600
a beast right now all right okay all
right that's what's up did you get
are you uh did you do you have summoner
from this current
yeah nice nice night
recently get the astral and i am
actually a fan of that
it's nice it maps wait i feel like it's
more consistent than fell winters fell
hunters has been driving me absolutely
insane lately i'm actually a certified
haircut
um stylist through my fellow winters
because that's all i do
um but the astral is really good yeah
overall you got a gastro
is really good love it in the kinetic
spot you know you literally can go
summoner or any 600 in energy and then
i'll say in kinetic astral but ash was
very underrated those two
yeah definitely by far the best i i feel
as far as the
current uh trials met a weapon so
yeah salute well to keep the crucible
chat going we know in season 12 we're
going to be getting some changes so i
want to get these two
expert ladies opinions about everything
we got changing at least for crucible
we're kind of going to cover it all
anyway
uh but starting with crucible you know
the director is actually going to change
going to be a little uh
leaner uh you're going to have control
elimination
rumble survival those are kind of your
main four
the weekly rotator clash mayhem showdown
private matches which you guys will be
living in anyway
still still gonna be there uh then of
course iron banner
iron banner freelance which i am
insanely excited about i'll
sorry i'll skip ahead on that one and
then trials of osiris with the option
of adept weapons now coming in season 12
not 13 which is also exciting yes um so
just very curious i guess about the
thoughts on the changes to crucible
is there anything you're sad to see go
is there anything that
you know i'm biased on one point that i
mentioned but what are you guys looking
forward
to come season 12 uh at least on the
crucible director
do i just need to call one of your names
to make you go yeah
so i'm like all right i'm not going to
say anything and then she doesn't it's
because i'm listening and i'm like wait
is she going to speak first
don't hold your breath for each other
you guys are both going to pass out
all right vixen you're first okay what
do you think
so as a sniper main i'm excited that
there's another sniper coming
um that i'm excited about that i
am excited that a lot of really bad maps
are leaving
i do hope that they are going to be
bringing in more maps
to counterbalance the fact that they
took out so many they took a a lot
yes um and
uh i'm i'm happy for freelance i guess
i don't i don't know
i'm i'm a fan of freelance foreigner
banner just to give
the solo player an option i have my wins
i have my losses and it feels like a lot
of mercies either way
and then sometimes close but i feel like
the freelance will give at least
a lot of the solo players somewhat of a
more level playing field hopefully so
there's not like
me and oh they're all in the same clan
this isn't going to go well because we
can usually guess if you're opposing
that team
it's not going to be pretty oh yeah i
mean it's nice
but i guess as a like a pvp main i i
really
rarely touch pve so when i go into iron
banner everybody's a raid boss
so yeah your light level's always like
you're like hey you're 10 80 what the
hell
600 rpms rate bosses it's the best that
is kind of an interesting i know for you
just in listening from garden royale and
talking you mostly do
pvp is it just the pve content doesn't
like excite you nothing there is
appealing to pull over
i mean granite recluse mountaintop have
all been good and they've only been a
pvp so you haven't a lot of hat
as much incentive but like how much have
you had to go percentage like do you
play pvp versus pve is it like
80 20 like 95 5 like how much how much
are you swinging in pvp i'm gonna be
honest
like 99.5 to 0.5 pvp
joking and it's so crazy because i
kept like in d1 i started out in pve i
was scared of pvp
and now i just i feel like maybe it's
because when d2 came out i was just so
i quit when d2 came out i didn't come
back until forsaken so maybe that's what
it was it was just
can i ask why you quit uh it was just
horrible we came from a sidearm meta to
another sidearm meta
and i was a pvp main at the time so i
was like why am i playing this
um so that's why that in
life life support and just in general as
far as getting you back in was it just
more so
you heard the good things about forsaken
was it more things about the meta people
people saying pvp has changed
like what said okay you know what let me
get back into it let me see what's going
on
a lot of people on twitter were saying
that pvp is gonna feel
like d1 again and that was important to
me
and it felt good for a while and now i'm
roped back in
and good god what happened
[Laughter]
she's back absolute salute
so foxy what about you anything on the
new director changes that you're looking
forward to
or sad to see go
um i'm excited for freelance iron banner
too
because i'm not a stack person
like at all and it's mainly because of
the way it plays and because of lobby
balancing like i always feel bad because
even when i'm not in quickplay a lot but
even when i am
okay
oh no yeah that's all good
oh gosh she's bringing it over okay
that's totally funny
i am even when i'm just in quickly do
pinnacles or stuff i always have people
like coming to chat asking if they can
join and i feel so bad because i'm like
i don't want to be in a party bigger
than two or three because the lobby
balancing just gets like
weird and i don't want to play stacks
like
so i'm i'm excited for a freelance
option because i'll probably actually
like grind out pinnacles on that and
stuff
um for next season it's fun every once
in a while to like six stack with a team
everyone's done it at some point right
like and just roll through iron banner
like yeah it's fun for a little while
but
make other people on the other side very
sad for a bit yes
so i'm excited for that i'm excited for
it to look a little cleaner it's getting
a little busy right
yeah for my tastes but 12 buttons later
it's like what do i need to click on
yeah i might i can never remember
because i like i launched private
matches so much i
that's the only one i just like bottom
left bottom left bottom left like
everything else i'm like i don't know
what all this is
is there i was gonna say is there
anything you guys would like to see
because i know they're pulling stuff
out of like they're pulling a lot of
things out of the game you see the
director getting smaller planets leaving
maps going modes going
we don't have a lot of news of what's
coming
now granted they probably haven't told
it to us yet either but is there
anything you would like to see added in
whether it be now or later with being as
they're making so much quote space in
the game
i gotta call the name foxy yeah i gotta
do this okay they are not gonna
stop each other foxy you're first what
do you want to see
i would really like to see some d1 game
modes like skirmish and i didn't even
play much pvp in d1 but like skirmish
would be nice
rift would be nice like some unique type
game modes to come back would be really
cool
um i also think it would be cool if they
bring back some d1 maps like i know
a lot of people want asylum back i think
that would be cool
so i won the day actually yeah like i
would be down for some of that stuff for
sure
maz seems to want asylum i can't quite
tell yeah
yeah yeah
what about you vixen what do you want to
see come back if she didn't steal at all
i was gonna say asylum and skirmish um
and personally take control out of
these the solid and make it clash please
dear god nobody knows how to play a an
obj
nobody knows how to do it just just just
stop it
standard team deathmatch just like yep
yes respect it
please just give me clash
that'll be cool especially i miss when
iron banner used to kind of mix
them up once once a season i want to see
a different one i'm with you
yeah just oh my god iron banner rift at
one time was that d1
yeah yep yes iron banner
would be i would enjoy that i would
actually want to play iron banner like
that
needs a little variety you know
something don't get me wrong i love
control i love
the iron band the lock the points thing
it just it gets redundant sometimes so
you just need a little spice you know
just mix it up
you know having a rotation this week one
control does come around like you kind
of appreciate it a little bit more
then every week it's meat and potatoes
again
here we go like every come on like you
know so for me it's just
you know i i do miss when you know clash
used to come up and i
said ref just something crazy just to
mix it up because people you need that
variety
i want mayhem iron banner one time oh
god no dear god
and they gotta adjust the bounties they
can't be they got to be like specific
you know iron banner mayhem bounties but
that i'm just if it was just like
once for the entire year they're like
hey we're throwing a wrench into
everything
iron banners mayhem this one time this
one season i'd be like
cool you guys get your classes every so
often i want my mayhem
once a year it's just vixen's everything
no
i remember one when they had like the oh
my god i'm gonna sound like such a
downer
the fun stuff in trials whatever like
halloween was around and they took away
your radar
and then they had the random like
spiders did it come out yes
yes oh why yeah i remember that
i remember that yeah spooky trials
that's what you used to call it spooky
oh boy yeah she took me back i do
remember that they messed around
it was how long would you say probably
like a bun
god i don't i screamed every single time
that spider came down i was so mad
so there you go they do that now no
yeah facing a dawn blade with a solar
empowerment for 12 minutes that's pretty
spooky to me
[Laughter]
[Music]
definitely so we got got some different
modes going on you know
like they consolidated right you yeah
just kind of wrapping everything
together
so it's just more concise i mean you
open the director especially
they're going to have new light players
with xbox getting game pass and all that
stuff going on we're gonna have
a whole bunch of new players coming in
so if they look at that they're like
where do i even play what do i do don't
know what things are
so i'm glad they're consolidating it
quite a bit to hopefully make it a
little bit easier
but going back up to a point that i
wanted to ask about i know you're a fan
of beloved
specifically so the fact that you're
getting beloved's like
once removed cousin with a scarf
and then it's got three different reps i
wanted to ask about the whole like
kind of almost a re-issue for now you
may love snipers it may have some
different perks to it but how do you
just feel about the fact that it's
this is your pursuit for season 12.
now you're biased on snipers but do you
think this is like a good direction for
them to go with the different
skins on it or just what are your
thoughts overall i'll start with you and
then foxy or next
i mean destiny's always been infamous of
reskinning
every single thing we get like it's it's
that's all destiny weapons are it's just
a long
drawn process of getting reskinned stuff
um i've kind of like given up on being
mad about that anymore because it's just
i expect it now everything's just gonna
be a reskin
uh so i'm kind of like yeah it's beloved
but make it pretty
it's beloved it's adored actually is the
name it's called the adored sniper rifle
they didn't even get too far away in
name yeah they didn't even ch
i mean see that's that's one of those
points was like i get it we're gonna get
reskins now for me when i have literally
two night watches please get scout some
love please anyway
moving beyond that i have two night
watches from like season the drifter or
at least the icon
and two night watches from this season
the exact same perks
yep like and they're sitting in my vault
and i'm like i've been staring at them
and i haven't wanted to make the video
but i want to make the video about like
this shouldn't happen and just kind of
seeing this is
it's a little worrisome i guess about
the pursuits is
well i saw somebody do like a reskin of
mountaintop with a scarf on it and then
i was actually terrified but
i think that they're finally just
embracing the fact that everything's
just
re-skinned like this is basically just d
d one
just just take off the two just just d
that sounds bad sorry just destiny
[Laughter]
sorry so good you're good after dark
podcast here
but no like cognito i wanted to ask you
do you have any opinions about like the
the reskin i've seen it been going
around that's kind of why i wanted to
bring it up
so i mean you know kind of kind of work
with vince's as like it's just what they
do at this point you know what i'm
saying like as long
my whole thing as long as it's balanced
as long as there is enough
new things added in conjunction with
this then i'll be fine
but if we start getting a whole laundry
list of remixes
then i'm gonna have a problem you know
saying so for me it's just like you know
the gun looks cool you know it's always
been a strong gun obviously
um you know they had to you know come up
with i guess some form of replacement
for it now that the old one's gonna be
sunset
you know i would like you know newer
stuff but
this is this is what they're doing but
lo as long as it's more
new stuff as a whole it's a bigger piece
of the pie
as as opposed to like we're going to get
this now we're going to get
you know we're going to see a whole
bunch of the stuff that sunset
renamed with that like then i'm out like
bungie no
like we can't do that we can't do that
so that's where i'm at without
it's like i'm watching them i got my eye
open i see what you're doing
but let's let's make sure we don't cross
the line continually with it that's
where i'm at right now
boxing i mean oh vixen no no you go you
you get an opinion
i was just gonna say their only attempt
at something new recently was wither
horde and i
absolutely hate it just take that back
oh really
well okay so you're not yeah you don't
you're not so much on the pve
do you hate fighting against it or just
like oh yeah
like especially in control like what are
you supposed to do if they throw down
eight at b
what are you going to do that point is
there for a minute
yeah with a haunted control it's just
it's just obnoxious
it's kind of a mess but also kind of fun
it's
yeah it's like but it is like i like to
see those types of things to see them
stretch their creativity be like
this is brand freaking new and
especially you could get like an orb
drop and you see that purple thing
coming at you like oh crap
um but yeah wither horde has been well
wither horde and ruins i was thinking of
ruinous effigy that one too
um they've both been they they have been
interesting exotics to see
that and then unfortunately to see your
pursuit weapon for the season
is got a scarf on it that was kind of a
bit of a letdown personally
foxy what do you think you're shaking
your head i don't know where you fall
um i agree i think it was a bit of a let
down especially with like um
i thought rooney's effigy was super cool
same with the weather horde
no like they're not the funnest to fight
against in pvp but
i always try to keep in mind that this
game is like
vastly pve focused um
and the dubs have made that very clear
as well so i just tried to like
take everything they put in the game
with a grain of salt as a pvp player
um especially with like uh i thought
divinity was really cool too
like seeing those types of ideas and
then
seeing adored i i almost feel like
they're kind of like
like that keck w mean meme i think
they're actually laughing at the pvp
community a little bit because
if you think about the the last three
things we've gotten right is adored
which is a reskin with a scarf
and has like a laughable name yeah
the last title we got was flawless
yeah it had five objectives to it
and now we're getting we're gonna get
frozen
and taken like our abilities our
handling everything's getting taken away
from stasis and they get like stacey's
oh say i have a lot of issues with
stasis oh we're getting there next let's
see
spicy taste let's go i just feel like
i'm like
just not expecting anything now as a pvp
player like if it pops up it's going to
be cool but i know the majority of it's
going to get banned in pickups and
that's what i spend most of my time in
so i'm just kind of like
uh okay so the whole the renewed focus
over the crucible and the pvp you feel
they haven't quite lived up to that
promise
uh no
i think we have different definitions of
renewed focus
like a renewed abandonment thank you
harsh harsh but honest i like it
we neglect it out here the pvp community
is neglected
out here they need some love i agree i
agree i think it's
it's long and it's a shame because the
pvp and destiny i i always love it
it's a it's a nice fun balance you still
have your you know
as far as your gun mechanics and stuff
like that but to me what makes it so
cool is you still have the abilities the
supers all these other little cool
additive things to it
and whether it be the balancing or
you know just the lack of attention you
know season after season it just it
feels like
everything is so pve focused and i get
it you know it's huge community
but we've got to not ignore this
big portion of the game and they've got
to see these numbers you know i'm saying
they've got to see these engagement
numbers as far as
the community and i would i really you
know i don't know if it's a resource
issue but at the end of the day
pvp has been suffering for a while it
really needs more attention
well i mean that's the thing too we have
quiet times in every season
it doesn't matter what season could be
an amazing season could be
season of the unworthy doesn't really
matter but whatever you do
there's lulls because no company can
constantly put out content
right we're seeing that obviously right
now with the delay and that's totally
fine but we have september which is just
literally gonna be iron banner they
could probably do it four times in a row
and that's pretty much all they'd throw
at you
yeah i mean but to the point is like
what keeps the game up alive or what
keeps people in a moment
people doing you know pickups and scrims
like you ladies do and then tournaments
and stuff like that
the pvp side is one of those things
trials is what gave destiny 1
the legs it even had to make it to
destiny 2.
that was one of those pieces so the fact
that they don't
really seem to give it hardly any focus
anymore especially when there was that
like
promise for more in the renewed and
we're going to be keep looking at it and
the only thing that i've seen so far
besides obviously a beloved [ __ ]
is the fact that you know the trials
weapons are going to be potentially
seeing adept weapons in season 12
not 13 so they're coming a little sooner
that works with the delay
and the delay helped that one which is
cool but it's just that's
yeah it's kind of an underrated piece
that's all so go ahead the thing
for me when i again when we're getting
adorned and all this stuff
you know i'm like okay cool ritual's
coming back all right cool
but i gotta be honest e like for me what
kind of sets me is that
you know i miss each mode
having its own pursuit right now i get
this mentality where it's like okay
we're gonna let you play the mode you
like and then you get this
but it's like still one weapon right
so it's like you know at the end of the
day what made
recluse and luna and all this stuff
attractive is they made me go
in that mode and play pvp and you saw a
lot of the pve community
coming into pvp to say look man luna
looks good i got to get recluse
like that's how you kind of lure people
in even when thor
existed like you had to go in there and
get do little
achievements and goals towards getting
thorn and stuff like that they've got to
do more of that to encourage people to
at least try pvp there's a huge subset
of the community not these two amazing
ladies
but you know that just don't touch pvp
and i'm like
man it's fun they got it they have to do
more of it so
you know what in one hand i'm glad
rituals are coming back in a way
but in a sense one is not pinnacles and
two we need more
pvp specific things and then i would be
a little bit more excited yeah it's like
the only reason
i ever jumped in comp typically because
i've never been
not my thing just never been as much my
ballgame but like
to go after recluse to go after i can't
tell you mountaintop how much i want to
pull my hair off
i will say mountaintop made me better
with fighting lion and like those so
it's like myself
how much how good you got with it right
well i was like that was one of those
like things like everybody hated the
grind but i can tell you it's like
i'll go goof around with fighting line
in pvp and i'm not gonna claim to be
that good but i have some moments where
i'm like
i would not have even thought about just
toying with it for a match just to be
goofy if i wouldn't have gone through
that quest much less
ben and comp kind of honed some skills
and it's like in i'm
off my ball on pvp right now because i
haven't played in a while but it's like
when i'm in those moments and play and
when i get done and then i go play quick
play like my skills are actually kind of
sharp after doing something like that
versus now the fact that i can get that
pursuit sniper
do i really care about going to play
crucible just to get a skin
only if you're a completionist are you
going to go do that but if you just like
hey i love strikes and pve stuff
and i'm not really a pvp person there's
no reason to go in there now some people
be like ah thank you i don't have to i
get the option
but on the other side as you said
player-based population if there's no
incentive to go in there
they're not going to some people just
flat out won't
yeah yeah i think it's kind of cool what
they're doing in a sense
besides the fact that they're all just
re-skins that you can grind it
it looks like it's going to be in
different activities so you can get
different roles on that adapt weapon
for a dord and that kind of thing or the
pursuit weapon whatever they're calling
it
um yeah that's interesting like that's
kind of cool but that is also like
a double-edged sword because then it's
not pushing people into pvp
but at the same time it's a struggle
because i remember when the solstice
gear came out or when it was data mined
that people were gonna have to play like
seven trials matches or something like
that
so many people complained like or they
just had to defeat like 25 guardians i
think or something like that for the
like so many people were so upset and i
was just like
as a pvp player i have to do hours of
pve
right to get
to cut you because you you're on fire
you touch me
at the end of the day it just it drives
me mad
that people who play pve 100
and then they ask a small porsche just
to do one thing like oh
i can't believe i have to play trials
and get five wins it's like what about
the pvp only people who
have to do nothing but pve content like
where's the balance and the fairness
today i'm sorry fox you just
you had me going continue continue no
you're good you're good
that's pretty much my on my only gripe
i'm just like that's part of why we
don't get anything either because i'm
like
if if the majority of the community is
yelling every time they have to touch
pvp
of course why would the dubs give that
attention then like
what a step child with a step chap they
don't love us
they're like the legs under the giant
like carrying the box along
they don't realize they're actually
doing the work like behind the scenes
because
yeah it's like the pvp stuff is there i
mean the people who like play the season
stuff and then take a break and then
come back
those are your like you know two and fro
players they're gonna go back and forth
like a yo-yo the steady players
typically also incorporate crucible into
their play they're the ones that are
going to hang around longer usually
i have a question yes then how did you
feel about
the what was it we had to do certain
things to
unlock something i think it was a weapon
and
the pve people carried that
weight to get that because i wasn't
going to go play pve for whatever that
was
doing the public uh yes how do you feel
about that
i mean that's like kind of on the other
that's the balance
of hey shotguns are that useful in pve
not really but then it's like it was a
cool i could see the story tie into it
which is
when we get into lore discussions and
stuff like that talking about fell
winter and like obviously with rasputin
and all of those
things the story piece to get the weapon
worth every penny
but the fact that like what is basically
meant to be
destiny 1's epic pvp shotgun version 2
was through public events yeah i don't
know
that was well i mean the fact that it
was 9 million public events after the
fact that none of them throughout the
first like 10 weeks of the season
counted
that wasn't handled the best so i mean
hopefully they've learned their lessons
a little bit
it would have been cool to see hey go do
public events
also go get shotgun kills in pvp like
that's the point where i could see like
hey everybody gets a little bit those
are the times i like to see the options
where it's like
both sides of you know your pvp players
you're gonna go with shotguns and just
it's going to be apes in there for a
little while while this quest is going
on
the people don't want to go ape it well
you guys can go in pvp
or pve and go you know tear your eyes
out during public events you pick which
one you want to do
right but i was like that's one of those
where the options is good but on the
other side when it comes to this pursuit
weapon when you have too many choices
that you avoid a part of the game bungie
never has an easy way to
like is never going to win ever for
everybody
so it's like they try and give options
out there but also sometimes
yeah it's kind of sad to see that the
options for the new pursuit is going to
allow
even more people to avoid pvp it's all i
was getting out no i agree i agree and i
i think to me the sweet spot was when we
had recluse when we had luna
we had those things that were in either
competitive and stuff like that
and made you you know i think our sanity
said something he was like on his way to
try to get
mountaintop he ended up getting recluse
you know and i i just
miss hearing you know those type of
stories and then people actually getting
better people like yo you know what
i actually enjoyed it i actually you
know found some strats and i was really
getting into it you know kind of thing
and that's how you balance it because
i'll be honest like when i first played
destiny
i was very intimidated by pvp i did not
really touch
it well in the beginning you know saying
i thought it was a little strange i
didn't get into it and i forgot
i think it was the thorn quest that i
think was like the void kills or
something
and it made oh and d1 yeah and it made
me go
in and i'm just like you know what it's
not that bad i started getting into it
you know i said i started having some
fun and then
you know you know the the the fateful
story about just going into
uh into the tower and then seeing all
these people with this cool
gold egyptian gear and i'm like where
did you get this like what is that
like they like trials and i'm like i
need to play that because i need
i need to have this i need to look like
a pharaoh i did so that was when it all
it all started for me and that love of
it like
just doing my pinnacles like i'll go to
pvp first i do agree with you on e
i love the balance whereas either or
that you don't say as far as
getting bounties and stuff done but i do
miss having specific pvp pursuits
that to me is just really cool and
really fun and i hope they go back to
that
i mean same thing applies for gambit now
because if you can get everything
without playing game but that is going
to be a ghost town
yes i know people don't love gambit for
many reasons and we'll see if this new
version gets a little bit better
but like if you don't have much of
incentive to go in there in the first
place besides some bounties
it's going to be pretty quiet i have a
feeling so we'll just have to see but as
you said
specifically like hey the trial's armor
looks really cool
well we're getting a new set of armor
that was also very controversial on
twitter i saw
uh so we're gonna be adding a new set of
armor for the core playlist
strikes gambit and crucible the armor
will share a set of new geometry
with decals and shaders specific to the
activity we'll create new sets like this
every year
year four year five year six uh and this
set will arrive alongside each
fall expansion basically um i wanted to
get you guys thoughts on the armor and
also the
knife by the neck situation uh the
accidental trip and kill yourself but
uh just want to get you guys thoughts on
the armor if you guys were liking this
set for kind of like the annual
armor set or if you guys are just like
it's fine or
just your opinions in general whoever
wants to go
just talk i don't know what how i don't
personally let's go i don't know what
happened to who was
designing gear but i need that person to
come back because d1
had so much like just aesthetically
pleasing gear to grind for and like you
just kept
doing things over and over again to make
sure you were trying to get that gear
and now it's just
boxy and uh ugly
i'm sorry just keep telling say it
louder
people in the back with the d1 versus
the d2 stuff look at this
she's like they're listening to me these
mans is this
[Laughter]
who said yes who hit the c who hit the
go button on
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so with you on
this i was just like i wonder what they
gonna say cuz i know what i'm gonna say
boxing miss my kitty cloak
um i agree it's very just
boring to me um the thing i've never
understood too
because i didn't play much d1 at all
i played for like two months maybe
before d2 came out
so i did like one raid i never touched
trials
barely played pvp and d1 so i've seen
pictures of the armor and i've seen
other people's characters but i didn't
get to go and get it myself
but i'm just like where did that
creativity go and also
why is it so hard to take advice from
this community that they constantly
praise and say is creative and amazing
they have community focuses they have
community highlights they have movie of
the weeks but you can't work with
someone who drew
like a badass armor set and put that
into the game
i don't understand that yeah i saw one
for shadowkeep
it's been running around twitter for a
while and that armor looked
amazing it looked like the aesthetic of
like the red and the spikes and the hive
overall
and oh no i mean d1 year 3 armor we've
talked about on the podcast before was
amazing from all the raids that you go
back forward and went through
and i don't know if they're afraid to
make things stand out too much if the
resource of that much detail costume i
don't know
what again this is a point where it's
like
as a you know just a human to human
conversation it's like
what changed no i'm not trying to be
mean or disrespectful i'm truly just
like
i'm not i was like this is what we got
in d1
we know activision's there we know
destiny 2 and forsaken you had multiple
studios but
what is the difference of designing what
i'm looking at in this picture
which is not exciting whether you throw
you know the vanguard orange and blue
which i'm probably never going to love
those colors so sorry zavala but it's
just
yeah that color combo is just not going
to do it now
unless you just like university of texas
burnt orange it's probably not your
thing
it's all like a picture like the hunter
at least in the front looks like it's
got the best shot of kind of being
okay yeah warlock's got a corset on the
back very thin waist there i see but
uh they've all got kind of the puffy
jacket thing going on and i'm like
texture wise it doesn't look terrible
but i'm just like when you look at d1
year three and then this is what you get
for this is like your armor for
the year yeah the whole year yeah
now is this just like hey if you get the
game for free this is like the base set
that you start with
and then your future dungeons your
future raids
if those look cool maybe this is your
base set but if this is what you
advertise as your one set of armor
not for season 12 for the year that's i
guess what's worrisome to me is
because these don't make me want to
grind i already got a big letdown
hold on i already got a big letdown
knowing that armor's not going to change
so like if you go into season 12 and
you're like cool i got a good set of
armor you're literally set for a year
like there's very little incentive
anyway if it doesn't look cool as it is
now there have been some cool sets of
armor half of them i feel like have been
ornaments from the season pass
yep and that's there you go i was like
somebody i forget who put it up on
twitter be like
hey these have been really cool sets and
i wanted to reply but i was just i bit
my tongue off and i was just like
one's a season pass oh that's another
season pass i was like oh these are
season passes
silver yeah so it's like if you buy the
season pass you get these cool ornaments
but it's like
the pursuit of armor that's what makes
some of that worthwhile
i'm hoping that um maybe it's going to
segue into what were they talking about
doing where you could
um transmog where you can make your
stuff look different
maybe they just aren't putting effort
into that to make other things look cool
so you can put
i don't know it just maybe
oh go ahead cognitively he's raising his
hands
[Laughter]
i'm curious too like and i don't know i
don't want to spoil anything because i
know it was technically like a data mine
thing
but who created the most recent like the
spooky armor sets that just came out
i don't know if you guys saw those
pictures and then why was that not the
same
because those are super unique and cool
but why is it not the same person who
created those that did the
like you have to remember those have an
eververse little price tag
attached to them with that little string
some correlation here all right
do i need to start the clock
this is just like a small correlation
i've noticed and that gets helped me
like get over not being frustrated about
some of this stuff it's just 100
a marketing thing because if you notice
too the person who wins the fashion
emblem every single week is someone
who's wearing an eververse set
so it's entirely i'm just being true i'm
just being honest like you know it is
and it's partly because it's the best
looking armor but partly also because
bungie gets to pick them
so i mean if i made something that was
making me money and then i made
something for
free and i was like you guys show me
which one you like better and i'll
all give publicity to it of course i'm
gonna publicize the one that made me
money
that's just a marketing thing so like i
understand it to an extent but i'm also
like
can we have a a little more balance
thank you
you you literally said without that
that's literally where i was going and
the correlation is
gonna be careful my words i love you i
love you buddy but
tess we gotta talk talk test
what is going on like all the best stuff
is always buried there and in
conjunction with all
the promotional events for example
solstice and
like those those gears because they want
you to grind
and they know if the gear is attractive
that incentivizes you right these
are core activities that we do every day
we grind
every day whether it be vanguard strikes
crucible
and gambit and to see this disparity
like it is so awful looking like
i'm just like why would i really want to
grind for this like
that that's my thing and like you said
it's like it's one of those things where
like if you make something attractive
you make
something worth getting that puts people
in that pool to
try to get it and right now it's just
not balanced
it is it is purely skewed one way
whether it be the eververse with the
ornaments
whether it be these events and we've got
we gotta call them out for it
if this is now like d2 i gave them a
pass when it first launched because i
thought they weren't that cool either
but it's like it's almost getting
progressively worse now like
it has been getting pretty bad yeah like
this is what i'm saying that our next
raid boss is going to be thin
church 100 that's where we are
that's where we are we are battling
tests
she's taking control she's the darkness
this is the darkness y'all sabbath is
working us
over for our wallets right now basically
she's the
she's the hidden object that you know
savage was going through but it's like
man it's just
it hurts me because again i mean don't
get me wrong the crew's in their defense
will look somewhat decent you know i'm
saying
i i like the color scream okay cool but
the other two
no it's not a goal we really need we
need some balance here we we have to get
this
a little bit more exciting you know what
i
mean
shout outs tess will be the new catalyst
is hilarious
she's sitting fat from strength right
now nowhere from fruit judge today
[Laughter]
this actually made me think though we
just we both just got done playing ghost
sushima amazing game by the way if you
ever played it
so so freaking good we'll have to talk
about that at some point um
but the way they handled the armor in
that game
they and that's something they could do
with this which i would actually like to
see take
these two ladies here play more pvp than
most of us know what to do with no but i
was like that's that's where you live in
the game especially vixen like you're
99 that's what you do say the crucible
decal
starts like this and then as you go
along
maybe you got you know 5000 pvp kills
that's a lot but you have a year to do
this type of stuff
and you're all like your decal gets now
like an upgrade
like the when you cooked and took goes
to sushi you get this like base arm and
you're like dude what are you wearing
like
not much right now yeah but when you
beefed it up to like level four
after all the resources you dumped in
the time that you farmed for stuff
you looked straight up like samurai head
to toe big armor pieces
if they would start here and be like hey
if you do
say it strikes like your 200th strike
your decal goes bam your decal is now
level two
some way to take these these are your
bases but these quotes decals in the
thing that you live in and be like
man that hunter armor looks amazing how
does it look like this
i've killed 10 000 people in the
crucible and i put my time in this year
and i look like a crucible badass
i love that idea that would be they take
the geometry
and then like you know how long is it
going to take people to get up to these
numbers they've got some time to be like
okay we'll decal
if you've made it to this bam decal
level 2's in there the next season i'm
going to open up level 3 if you guys
have made it there already
these ladies already have 20 000 pvp
kills because they live in it
cool now you can see what level 3 looks
like that'd be you could build on those
armor sets and give you incentive to
stay in those activities
if any private matches please make sure
those count especially for these two
like a kill's a kill so uh
just something like that would be really
really cool yeah like titles as well
same thing like
something like you know flawless for
those who actually do trials flawless
start getting the roman numerals or
bigger gold around your right something
to set it apart
like an overwatch where your border like
either gets gold or
diamond or like multiple different stars
um i think yeah
yeah yeah absolutely i think at one
point i said that um
what's that glow that we just got with
that new solstice armor
that we had to do like 10 years worth of
pve for
yes um like you could do that
but like have like a different color for
pvp or
or just anything i agree
you're on fire because this what we're
seeing should be like
the base remember we with solstice
started right
it should be the base the broken zero
tarnish that yeah right and this way you
begin and just like you said how they
were making us do all these crazy things
and getting all these orbs all these
different ways
the it should be activity focused per
each you know
piece head you know whatever arms boots
whatever a class item
and make you do different thing and
really expound and get more majestic
as you go that keeps you engaged right
and then how cool is it when you see
another guardian
and they're decked out because they've
unlocked all this thing that really
looks makes them look majestic
now you've you create engagement you can
create and create investment in the mode
and that's what they got to do but they
bungee gotta hide my man he's on fire
hi he's giving you giving you game
bungie this is what we got
you got the tools that's what you got to
do
that's just i mean that's one of those
we need reasons to grind for all of this
stuff
like if the mods are going to be
somewhat minimal we'll get to stasis if
we still got time we'll get to it um
but it's like yeah these are going to be
exciting stasis talks from what i
uh gathered but like yeah we just need
reasons to grind for
this stuff like what's the decal gonna
be like am i ever gonna
i might trip into the decal for the
vanguard one
just by running enough strikes from all
the other stuff they typically make us
do
but i'm probably not gonna be like hey
do you wanna sit in the vanguard
playlist for a bunch of blues no
so do i ever care about like the
vanguard orange and blue in the first
place
and then i really still feel like the
knife right here that's a bad angle on
the titan because the other two it's
like over here like a quick
i understand those two but the angle on
the titan looks bad
it looks like it's off kilter either way
but yeah the the
pursuit the roar needs to the juice
needs to be worth the squeeze
like the time we put in and especially
if you're really dated
dedicated to one activity reward them
for it that's that seems like a good
thing but we got to talk about stasis
because
for one i know it's going to be an
interesting topic for pvp
i don't know what the landscape he's
going to be looking at already
we got a head shake we got like you got
the headshot ear to ear
let's go first are what do you guys
think about the new stasis powers and
which
uh which class are you going to jump on
for state are you just going straight
into your usual or
any other classes like tempting you at
this point what is stasis doing for you
guys and do you think it's going to
excite and mix up pvp or break it or
make you play a little differently what
are you thinking
luna says let it rip foxy yeah there you
go
cause i got to hit it
okay let's go i'm
as far as playing it i'm probably just
like gonna play all three there's not
really one specifically that i'm more
excited for
i will say that i guess my personal
opinion just because i know what it's
like playing a titan with dune marchers
that that looks a little bit
busted because if i can freeze people
and then shock them with lightning
and just punch them all and they die
like i'm gonna play that first i guess
but i think it's 100 gonna break pvp and
i think it's 100 a marketing strategy
again
because i think they're going to make it
look really cool to try to get as many
people back into pvp as possible
or on the game as possible in a short
amount of time
and then in a month or two however long
they decide to make a suffer they'll
probably say they're gonna nerf a few
things or rebalance some things or
whatever
um so i'm not really excited for it i'm
just like i said
relying on the fact that i have a
feeling a majority of it honestly is
gonna be banned
in scrims and pickups and tourneys
because
i do not see them like allowing titans
to just throw up another wall
and have a barricade and freeze people
with a ground slam
and same thing with hunters like i just
don't see that going over well
um especially not if the meta stays the
same because if i get frozen
and then sniped by a top tree john like
i'm throwing my mouse across the room
so luna we need that clip in real life
we need the phone clip of the mouse
throwing
we gotta get it yeah i think it's gonna
be pretty honestly pretty broken in the
beginning
it like i i hate to say it but every
time bungie releases something
super wise that's really big like this
like that a big update to the game
it's either broken or it's pretty bad
and it ends up getting a buff
so i'm leaning towards broken based off
the clips and the
descriptions for the brief descriptions
of what we've gotten they haven't even
fully let us know what all we can do yet
and it looks stupid so
you're not you're not excited for the
joys of being frozen by
another guardian you're not excited oh
no man i'm not
excited i am excited to use it a little
bit
but i'm not excited to have it used back
on me exactly
so yeah
all i'm saying is that when november
hits
i'm gonna need a parental advisory on my
channel
i'm gonna need you guys to mind your
business if you see me crying
just don't because i'm i'm a sixes maine
and that's where everything's most
broken
so you're telling me everybody on your
team goes in with the new
uh glacial wall grenade and you just
build a fort around point b with those
grenades you're you're not going to be
okay with that
i mean i'm just going to get bullied man
i solo so i'm going to get bullied i
already know it and i know
the top rotator is going to be mayhem
like
just disgusting
she's trying to keep it together
[Laughter]
together
they're bringing new content to destiny
too and it looks so much fun
and yeah free to play people are just
going to come through
and so insert pvp
words here insert stasis x
fortnight logo you create those
nightmares maybe
you know yeah can we get iceman flying
around in here please come on get some
wolverine i just got a copyright strike
damn it
[Laughter]
we're gonna have to have a a duo top our
adultage
of foxy and i just like throwing our
mouses and slamming something
it's gonna be i'm gonna get kicked out
of my house already now
concerns you though yeah it's like what
are you dreading
that's i mean can i say all of it
because
it all seems broken and i mean i'll i'll
admit like i want to play with the
broken for a little bit
i mean i'm very excited for the hunter
and
i'm excited for it but at the same time
like i know i'm not going to enjoy it
moving forward after
oh the fun broken phase bungie please
fix it they don't fix it for six months
like max you know we ain't getting that
balance update to the next path to the
next week
62 days three months straight yeah 362
days
oh no expansions coming out all right
cool
maybe we'll get a cool emblem
oh yeah
a whole bunch of snowflakes you survived
the the season of the whatever of the
stasis
remember the coolest damn emblem i've
ever seen in my entire life
pain and suffering and then like just
expletive just like ampersand
carrot percent sign dollar sign just
that's that's the name of the emblem
what is that this is what was said
during this time season of the pain
so we do actually have a little
clarification on the grenades all
classes get the grenades
because i was wondering about that
because i swore the hunter through it
first
then we're like the titan was the one
with the wall grenade everybody gets all
the grenades
um you got the glacier grenade that's
the one where you actually make the wall
whether it be vertical that we saw
in i can never remember that damn map um
it was a d1 map now d2 or the one like
the one in front of you where the hunter
was hopping over it
do you guys um i can't remember the
names off top of my head
um we used to be widows court if it
still is but
um see this is why i'm not a pvp mate
it was widows yeah sounds like that i'm
trying to think of the other one now
um but for that grenade itself
we know we actually get to create
geometry now the other thing they
mentioned when these things can
they can freeze whatever's inside or
nearby enemies
and when those things shatter piece by
piece they actually send out the stasis
crystals that do an aoe burst of damage
how how it's how excited if you were
pretend you're using it and you're the
one who gets to be broken and nobody
else has it
how do you see this being useful if
outside of the fact that you may hate it
but say you get to use it where do you
see this being the most beneficial this
grenade
so then this is going to kind of tie
into everything that's coming
um i think that
outside of pvp because i'm just going to
leave pvp alone um
pve i think it's going to be amazing
because it's gonna
add a new level of like combinations
that people can do
to get to any goals for bosses and stuff
i think that's cool
it's kind of like overwatch where you
can pair your
ultimates with other ultimates to get
things
to to get kills i think that's cool
yeah i agree with that i think it'd be
cool in pve
the first trailer that came out um
i've always been a fan of like
characters being
vastly different so like she used
overwatch as an example like i've never
played overwatch but i know a little bit
about some of the characters like
i don't know the uniqueness in like
those characters and like league of
legends and that kind of stuff i always
thought was so cool and obviously
destiny is a completely different game
but the small differences you had
between a titan
a hunter and a warlock i always thought
were really
interesting and how like you were
talking about earlier cognito like a
warlock can be really important to a
team as a healer and as a support player
i think that's awesome and i'm a little
upset that they're giving everyone
the same grenade and abilities now
because in the first trailer the warlock
was the one using the wall
and i was like that's cool like i think
that's really cool if only the warlock
has it right
right that person can be like a support
player they can block off lanes they can
do stuff like that that would be really
cool but now it can be
any of them and i see that just being a
little unnecessary
um i do think it'll be cool in pve i
guess
and it'll be cool in pvp if like one
person is running it but the problem is
is that
multiple people are gonna be running
everyone's gonna be running stasis
so that's going to be an issue so if
there's one broken grenade now you have
six broken grenades oh yeah that's a
good point
and she's nailed it because i i i love
what she said about the uniqueness
and it it because i i like when each
class has specific identity
and i think this doesn't do that it kind
of
gives everybody like now kind of yeah
like it took away the spice now that i
know that every
you know all three have that so i'm just
like uh you know
yeah so i i don't know if this is the
new direction though as far as like
you know with subclasses in the future
i'm a little concerned because i i do
like
you know i mean i think i mentioned it
last last word which was like
i was hoping you know hunters would get
like some type of specific support
ability from you know the class thing so
like for example you guys kind of do the
role right
but i was hoping like maybe with this
you know it would be some type of yeah
yeah like some type of support thing
that helps the team you know i'm saying
kind of thing
because i feel like obviously the
warlock with the rift healing
you know the titan barricade you know i
was just hoping that maybe hunters to
get something
that would help the team in that regard
but it seems like they're going a
different direction so
i do agree i do agree with you like i
i'm
i'm i'm just hoping that this is not the
eventual pivot on how subclasses of the
future are gonna go
well that's one grenade there's two more
don't worry
the cold snap grenade uh upon impact
with the ground or an enemy this grenade
unleashes a wave of stasis energy that
races along the ground in the direction
of closest nearby enemies
freezing them and then searching out the
next nearby foe you can freeze up to
three enemies with a single cold snap
grenade so picture what i'm guessing
arc bolt but now you're in stasis
i'm just getting this life you guys
can't if you guys if you guys are
listening to this on audio shout out to
all the audio listeners by the way
thank you that audience has been growing
so you guys are amazing um
if you could see the subtle head shake
of foxy right now
when i said those words oh go find us on
whatever youtube channel you can find
because as i finished that sentence i
was like who's going to talk foxy's got
to talk because that little subtle head
shake was just
so so sad um please please tell us about
this one
this is all i'm going to say right
trials last round
four out of four thermite basically
stasis grenade on the ground
freezes your entire team a top tree don
throws a [ __ ] melting pot at your
feet and
a spectral hunter wombos you and if you
manage to
like survive both of those you get wrist
rocketed by the top tree from 500 miles
away
so that just doesn't like that just does
not sound fun to me
like i don't know if i'm the only one
but oh you preach
you preach it uh dvp sounds yeah it's
don't be spooky y'all it's gonna be
spooky for a while we're gonna have to
i mean hopefully we're proven wrong but
i i agree i
i just can't uh vixx what do you think
are you are you nervous just keep us in
your thoughts dude just
whenever the new content drops just be
like yo
vixen think about you
think about you just pour one out for
him every night for the
whole multiple i don't know i mean
i want to be excited for new content but
like when you talk about situations like
that for trials
um i'm excited
i'm so i'm so excited
that was funny yeah it's gonna be like
again
these things awesome in pve i can
see the combinations the fun people are
going to have but
yeah pvp competitive sweats
with this kind of stuff is going to be
interest the only thing i can think of
is it
like the duration has to be extremely
short
you have to through because
don't get me wrong we love the
creativity we love you know when destiny
does
cool and unique things but again when
you have a pvp
side we got to see look i'm willing to
get on the benefit of the doubt
in the beginning but after the honeymoon
phase
and this stuff is still broken like i
really patched
we can't go through a whole season of
just having to deal with it
like they're going to have to be very
you know agile
if stuff is really breaking the
competitive space
that's my fault yeah hopefully they can
adapt quickly because
yeah just i didn't just thinking about
that yeah it's like if you have
celestial fire
after three grenades are frozen on a
control point just bam bam like
if you get two people running two people
could wreck an entire like
control point for a little while and now
with our uh wonderful new buddy
travelers chosen if you manage to like
start getting some stacks in there and
you get double of everything we just
talked about on one
person oh that's just terrifying but we
have one more grenade because you know
you gotta have three
number uh everything comes in threes the
dusk field grenade creates a powerful
stasis field that suck enemies into them
when they're forming
once an enemy is caught inside they will
be slowed and if unable to make it out
in time
frozen in place uh control points are
gonna be real sticky
[Laughter]
control points i thought i left black
holes in fortnight man
yeah so black hole of frozen-ness and
then just that little
and you guys are great the hunters with
your little throwing shurikens
just go in here bounce pounds pounce and
you know there goes the whole team
or half of one at least that with wither
horde good gun
oh lord that's all you need
literally wither horde in that grenade
just lock him in place and
dot him to death
you guys are so excited about these new
things i know they can't wait to just
dive into people i'm very excited for
pvp
help me now i did want to ask you guys
actually as well
when it comes to stuff like scrims and
things like that will you guys
potentially go as deep as saying certain
fragments and certain aspects
are or are not allowed because that's
that part of the customization
has potential to be cool i'm actually
kind of curious how deep they go with
that
but also will you guys go as deep as
saying this specific fragment or
thing can't be used are you guys more
just like hey this one
subclass is kind of off the table right
now
um i know for
um the script should have said a name
sorry
for the scrim coins rules we tried to do
a lot of testing
um and do stuff in detail like that
because we wanted to allow
as much as physically possible without
it being annoying or broken um
so i plan on doing the same thing for
this i'd like to test it out because i
don't want to take people's
customization away
especially since it's going to be a
whole new look as far as what you can do
with fragments and
things like that i think that's really
cool um
so i'd like to not just have to ban an
entire subclass
um i'm not sure what i know like
face it is a big organization that has a
pretty widely used set of rules
um same with like um d2 esports and
thieves and rules stuff like that i'm
not sure how they're gonna approach it
uh i think they're a little bit more on
the cautious side though
understandably especially because they
run tourneys for money and things like
that so
it's almost like better cautious than
not because if you allow something
that's completely broken and someone
wins a grand off of it then that's a
little bit harder to justify
than you know we didn't have a week to
go and test the details and the minutia
of all this stuff
um i would like to test it though like
pretty much in detail as soon as it
comes out we'll probably be doing that
in pickups to see
exactly how busted what is going to be
what type thing so now i will definitely
say as
hunters i think everybody is most
terrified of you guys though in stasis
us titans and the warlocks over here
when you can dodge and slow people down
and then if you throw gemini jester and
take away their radar at the same time
i'm a blind slow moving duck like i am
so screwed in that situation
[Music]
that was the one of the quickest things
i saw when the hunter stuff came out is
that slowing dodge ability
i mean the warlocks get to freeze with
their rift with like one little but you
guys just like oh hey
oh crap now i'm an icicle like that's
trouble so do you guys do you see that
as being a very powerful tool that you
like
i don't care what the other aspects are
that one's going to be living on mine is
that one that you guys see having a lot
of use for do you guys i guess it
depends on if you ate or not too
vixen is going to be like i'm doing
something else because i'm too far away
but
i have this weird sense of pride about
not using broken stuff
i don't know it's i feel like if i use
the broken stuff i'm not going to get
better
and so i put myself through pain
and i mean i do have nights where i'll i
call it daddy mode where i throw on the
600 rpm and chill
but um i don't know it's
i know i'm gonna get to a breaking point
i'm like i'm just gonna put on the
broken stuff
but i feel like i'm gonna try and stay
away from things like that like gemiini
jesters and and that together just
sounds
awful if you like the shotgun that's
just
if that's just terrifying that's just
such you slow them down they don't know
where to look and you're just like
let me line up my shotgun on their nose
gotcha
yeah yeah you won't even need that long
but still that
if you get into a group and if you can
go invisible on top well i guess you
can't combine both of those thank god
but if you had like
somebody throw an invisible smoke you
could run in on on another team
like you have one hunter oh man yeah you
can just start compounding the stuff
luna just said with um like well my
setup currently i get my dodge every
engagement like if i
am in an engagement and i kind of
readjust i have my dodge again
so you just constantly have that if it's
still set up like that
um it's gonna be gonna be fun
they're gonna have their their work cut
out for them on balance
that's just let's just say shout out to
the sandbox
those titan sentinel bubbles are gonna
be a whole new level of like please
protect me
i mean that's gonna be like your one
safe space is like you're gonna almost
have to play
defense against because while these kind
of have a prime and detonation with the
freezing and the shattering which is a
whole different discussion where you can
just be
blown away with a body shot by being
frozen um
that is the big thing about stasis is
it's not so much about offensive it's
just like
it's control of your environment
so you're going to have you can't just
you know throw a fire at it if if it
can't move you're if you can't move
you've got to find a different way to
play so i'll just kind of be curious to
see
as more and more people like build
counters to stasis if they don't
if it's not to the point of being like
yeah just go play stasis otherwise
you're stupid you're just
shooting yourself in the foot if there
are counters for this that really start
coming out and it like
completely shifts the meadow away i'm
that's kind of some of what i'm like
crossing my fingers and hoping for a
little bit a lot of it feels like it's
going to be broken
but if there are cool counters that like
hey i've got this wall i can shoot
through now or the titan bubble because
i got to lock down this point
i'll be curious to see like if things
shift that way that's kind of that's a
good point
yeah they have to come up they have to
prove to us that there are counters to
this style of play
because you know then it becomes a
little bit more fairly okay there's some
things we can do but if we
feel helpless and you can only counter
with this exact these type of abilities
then yeah it's gonna get
you know i'm kind of what fixing was
like i don't like having to resort to
you know the super sweaty meta stuff
that everyone else is using i always
like i always feel dusty's
best when there are multiple options
when there are multiple things that can
work and you can be successful with
as opposed to all right everyone
throwing the stasis and freeze the world
like hey
calm down like that that's just me you
know
so let's see let's see again i'm willing
in fairness
because we haven't touched it we have we
know we we see it we
we are concerned all of us
but we i'm willing to give them the
benefit of the doubt but like i said
after
the honeymoon phase is over we have now
determined
things that are really op you know i
really would like them
to be a little aggressive with
controlling
some of that stuff especially yeah
i kind of feel the pain too for titans
because
i i always say like when people ask me
why maine i'm honestly like a titan and
a hunter main because i
play them pretty much the same amount um
and i play warlock a decent amount too
but a little less than the other two
but like i feel people who are just
tight in maine's pain right now because
every time i jump on a titan
i'm just like the mobility is so lacking
and now if you're getting frozen
on top of that and every other subclass
has a or every other class has a dodge
except for you
like i i might play titan in pubs but
i'm going to avoid it in every other
situation because it's just pain
like being that slow it's painful right
now i'll just be walking around with my
concrete shoes on it's fine
it's going to be interesting
well yeah stasis is definitely going to
change some stuff up we did actually get
some other
a little bit of positivity they actually
did mention like we know the directors
are
consolidating down but one high note
actually they said they're also looking
to add adept weapons for
strikes yeah in a future season and not
that was
probably the highest point we know
gambit's being consolidated i'll be
curious how that feels if they can ever
find the sweet spot for that
if exotics are in there it's still
probably gonna be broken if you can use
like xenophage and stuff but
adept weapons from strikes actually has
me intrigued i don't know
what that's gonna entail what is gonna
come from those
but the fact that that's actually on the
table is the first time we've seen that
i was curious if that like
piqued your interest how you guys think
that would work is it just gonna be like
part of the legendary pool or the strike
specific loot cause some of the strikes
are gone now curiously you guys thoughts
on that one
um i think that's kind of exciting too i
thought that was cool
my it's like yes earlier for like the
pvp pve ratio
i'm probably closer to like 70 30
like maybe that aspect i enjoy pve um
i enjoy raiding and stuff like that i've
done all the raids with my clan mates
um i find that kind of stuff intriguing
the dungeons are
i thought were super cool so to hear
that maybe strikes are getting that
like a little edge i thought was kind of
nice um because
i grind those too for you know materials
and all that kind of stuff like that
would be my chosen activity to grind for
for mats at this point in time so i do
like enjoy
when they give pve stuff also i think
that would be cool if they could uh
i think it'd be cool if they could do
like themed type stuff too like if they
dropped an adapt weapon like for
sabbathune
i would i know immediately like i would
go after that because that's my favorite
aesthetic from destiny is like that dark
hive type vibe
so let's go let's go yeah
god any any strikes that you think as
you said might
might hit your wheelhouse for aesthetics
or thematically that you'd like to be
like
i want to go grind out olive lair for
whatever i mean there's so many i mean
the thing is i i like the the idea of it
i like the idea of
having that debt but the key is going to
be what though like
you know i kind of want them to push the
envelope a little bit you know
i don't want them to be super safe and
sometimes they have a tendency to be
super safe with it
you know like what's going to be the
adapt perk
you have two perks instead of one it's
not going to blow my skirt up it's not i
need
listen destiny's always fun you know
when they they push limits a little bit
so
i'm hoping you know i feel like since
they went
from pinnacle to ritual weapons it's
gotten safe
and those rituals go into pursuit so it
feels like it's going safer
so yeah and like i said so
in a perfect world i would like you know
strike specific loot
in conjunction with this you know little
depth thing and then i'll be
excited but i got cautious optimism i i
like that they're thinking about this
and that there's something's going to
happen but i'm not necessarily sold i'm
going to be really
liking it yet i hope to be proven wrong
and this stuff really is exciting and
it's really wow like this is cool
it's a depth such and such you know but
i'm kind of like
i gotta see first after seeing that
armor
you didn't make me question everything
that's where i'm at gotta be excited
about it before you jump on the on the
train
yeah what about gmx
[Laughter]
i feel like i sound like a debbie downer
all the time i'm excited for new content
like it's it's great like i'm glad that
we're getting new stuff
but i'm such a pvp maine that i don't
want to go play hours of pve for things
i don't that's just not my thing okay
and would you go
granted anti-cheat's a big part of this
equation uh the trials adept weapons if
those come
like those will potentially be coming
with beyond light
that's at least in your wheelhouse so if
those are
say on par with the strikes would that
seem like kind of a fair balance for you
yeah okay um i mean
yeah you seem very sure about training
very very very loosed about this
i i just recently started playing trials
again yeah um
my happy world would be uh skirmish 24 7
and grinding something for that but
this is the world that we're in now and
um i don't know i feel like it
yeah let me ask you this what about i
know i know how you feel about pv
but what if um you find out
that one of these adept or you know
pursuit weapons
are really beast see i was
just about to say something about how
mind benders you had to grind
pve forever to get it and i um nope
so wait you did you're like i'm not
doing it no i never got a
a mind benders wait
i do have one but i don't know how i got
it i didn't i didn't
well if you got your travelers chosen
recently you got one but i don't know if
you've had it for longer than that
i've had it for longer than that um
i did recently do the traveler's chosen
thing just to say that i did it
and i don't know it's like
it's like a slow hair pull it's just
it's just
to me i just don't enjoy it i don't know
what it is like d2s pve is just so
it's repetitive i think is what it is
i mean it's you're not completely wrong
because i mean as we went down
memory lane for all of the travelers
shows and stuff first it was like hey do
a weekly bounty
go to these planets we've had for years
and go shoot stuff
okay go into the lost sector go into
this last sector go do this strike go do
this strike
and here's your gun so it's like it was
kind of it was a trip down memory lane
for the stuff that was leaving so i kind
of understood
why they put those objectives with the
traveler's chosen quest which the gun
itself is actually not bad um i've seen
people have some pretty crazy builds
especially for like quick supers and
double grenades and things of that
nature
for both pvp and pve i'm sure it's got
some use but
i don't know it's like it feels like
when you were talking about the thorn
quest that you went through
and you had to get the void kills in pvp
and i remember i was just like
my void was a choice in d1 when that was
the thing
my void weapon choices were awful i had
like a void
trash shotgun and maybe a hand cannon i
was terrible with hand cannons on top of
it
so like for me to get thorn was a bit of
a pain
yeah but i also knew it was one thing
that i really wanted to get so
i did it now granted was it
more fun less fun than the same old
stuff
i guess that's a debate and i guess this
brings us back to is like we've been
doing some of the same stuff for six
years so some of it is getting
a little long in the tooth so i mean
we're sun setting
and sun setting without too much
reissuing but you know as they'd use the
destiny content vault
this i don't know the fall is going to
be a big tell of i think
what potentially in the next three years
could be like so the cautious
the cautiousness i think a lot of us
have right now is we're seeing some of
these things
a lot of us i feel like are hoping
they're like filler to get to what
hopefully is a better place in the
future because if
if it's more and more of these types of
things that's kind of worrisome
mm-hmm valid very very valid we got to
see it's kind of like a wait-and-see
thing
let's see how this thing's going to play
out you know again i just don't want it
to be
so subclass focused and the content is
not rich so
i just like i say that's just my main
concern they've gotta
nail this thing as a complete package
and you know just waiting to see
give them the benefit of doubt until i
see otherwise yeah
i'm a little worried about those adept
weapons and the strikes being
really good in pvp i kind of wish they
would make i mean
they have to know what roles on certain
weapons are going to be loved by pvp
players and what aren't at this point
like they had to know when they released
spare
and mind benders with those roles and
those options that those are going to be
loved in pvp
yes so it's a little frustrating to me
that i had to go and grind reckoning
which no one
who even loves pve wants to do and i had
to go do
i did over 200 hollowed lairs for my
mind benders and i still didn't get a
god roll
and then i had to go do menagerie for
beloved like
that kind of stuff is just really
frustrating and while the menagerie
grind was a little more like
customizable and easier
which is great i really wish they would
either just
pvp weapons earned in pvp and pve
weapons earned in pve
or require both for everything like
or give an option for both for
everything like i wish they would do
that instead of like
go do 1200 strikes to get this god
rolled sniper for pvp and i'm just kind
of like
okay i guess so i mean like i don't want
to but sure
i kind of i don't know how long does it
take to do the solstice gear with all
the pve
it was like a three hour task maybe i
don't know just do that but
pvp yes yeah not like what he suggested
with the arbor
and having you know kills and certain
things or
subclass you know they could they could
get creative with it and make goals
within the pvp
i completely agree
it would be nice at least to get some
variety in there but yeah it's like i
mean as you're saying if you let
if you have too many options like a lot
of people as the game leans heavy pve
is gonna make the pvp community smaller
it is part of the game unless they just
want to completely take it out or make
it separate
they still need to make sure that's one
of their pillars like
gambit was like an attempted pillar of
like strikes gambit
crucible gambit is getting some rework
and
gambits even get like hey these two
modes that we tried with reckoning we're
taking reckoning out these two are
coming together we're changing up the
blockers and the timing and the invaders
yeah i haven't seen that much rework to
anything crucible i think since destiny
2 started
yeah i mean the fact that like hey
here's control
okay
i mean regular just team deathmatch is
going to be team deathmatch or clash
whatever you want to call it
that's still going to be what that is
but we haven't had rift
we haven't had that many new modes we
haven't had a whole lot of variation
and i know pvp is still going to be that
it's going to be an arena shooter type
thing
but the fact that gambit's even getting
that material working cruciblism is one
of those where you're like where are
where where does crucible really lie
because is it live
what's your show with the cards you're
showing us are crucibles like the
redheaded step child in the corner dude
i was about to say i feel like the
child that my mom forgot me at the
grocery store
we neglected we're absolutely neglected
and shout out to uh prescott he's asked
a question he didn't play d1 for long
was it better
pvp ecosystem where pvp people could
just stay there and get what they want i
agree i think there was because
i remember iron banner specifically like
i would in d1 i would get excited
to know what the iron man and weapon of
the week i remember things like
nirwin's mercy and clever dragon and
these were these
really outstanding weapons that i made
me jump into pvp to grind for and get
better roles for
and when you look at iron banner and d2
and it's just like
okay we're gonna we're going for this
again like it's the same weapon
the same or like there there's no change
like they bring iron
banner back but it's grind the same two
weapons again you know
like it's it's what so literally it's
just become
a pinnacle activity for for light as
opposed to
actually getting weapons in the crucible
that are new and exciting like they just
completely have abandoned that
and that i even remember if you remember
e with d with d1 with um iron banner
they used to be like armor-specific
perks that would like help you with the
control point
faster or something like that like i
think i remember that yeah that's
actually been
all there's so many perks that are iron
banner title win
that too teddy yep iron banner like
it it convicts you said it but it's we
are the neglected
pillar like it it's just we are
forgotten it
it we'll get to it when we get to it and
i get it pve probably the the metrics
shift that way but you have this mode
that you've even had a foundation indeed
one of things that you've done that were
successful
yet they choose not to implement them
i'm just like i don't
get it it really frustrates me and i i i
just want pvp to have that same
attention and fairness looked at the
same way pba is and then i'd leave them
alone but
i would still be still be talking to you
but
you're not going to hit the slap in the
face that kind of like
made me stop getting so angry about it
was the lord of wolves emblem
thing like it was broken for so
long and they slapped him and blew on it
you could have made the gun inactive you
could have done
anything but you you said huh have fun
remember parethis lens was the same
thing one weekend at least that was
quicker
yeah it's just why does the sandbox
update take so long
it feels like they do it on purpose
sometimes it genuinely feels on purpose
it's like the
community they can't stand so they put
you through
bs to
keep coming back for more yeah no it's
it's
it it's absolutely true you know you
just you just want them
to bring that attention and like i said
i don't know again
resource or whatever but we got it still
got to change it's just not
in a good place at all
yeah i had honestly totally forgotten
about the iron banner
perks i mean there's they're going away
with the gambit
perk sets like so these things that have
been
i mean teasing teddy like shout out to a
previous guest that gentlemen
hope you're doing well um he said think
about this for a second we're entering
year 4 of destiny 2.
we've surpassed destiny 1 in terms of
time and support
think about how many quality of life
things from d1 still aren't in d2
and aren't even coming with the next
like full expansion dlc
like that's i know they made a big shift
for like d1 year one we had like
everybody calls it the casualization we
had the two primaries all that stuff
forsaken was cool we got random rolls
back and moved around the slots and
those things
but as you're saying like iron banner
it's been the same two weapons for an
entire set of
i feel like it's going to be a six month
season because it almost was and it's
the same
two weapons plus we the amount of things
that we got like
and as you said a new weapon or two
every week that we got to go for and
then the last iron banner of the season
was hey now you can go for all the ones
in case you missed it
yep that was why you played throughout
the season to be like oh this iron
banner i get like chances at this one
as opposed to your now your weapon loot
pool of like 30 weapons at your basic
vendors and stuff like that
the crucible vendors and everything of
that nature so
it's i don't know they've they set a
really a decent bar by the end of dear
one
d1 and like d2 has some things that have
done right but there's
there's all these little pieces and
we're talking about crucible for
well it's about two hours now but i feel
like the things that i mean but that's a
good thing that's why you guys are here
so i was hoping this would be this way
but when we talk about crucible for two
hours it doesn't feel like the shifts
that you guys want in crucible
are major it's not like hey i want like
armor
stats to be like stupid rpg stuff that i
want pve and all these
you guys want like just a little bit
more focus like give me 10
more from all of this other stuff that
you do
as opposed to build me a new planet you
guys are just like
hey can we tweak these modes and
balancing and yeah i know sand bouncing
back
sandbox balancing isn't like the easiest
thing because they're trying to balance
an entire crazy game
but like i feel like you guys aren't our
are not asking
they're not asking for that much and
they're like can i just get like a
little
just a little dude i don't know maybe i
just don't understand
video game development but like
the just the blocking the blacking out
the
gun the lord of wolves i don't
understand why that was so
difficult or impossible because it was
unbearable at some points
oh but they're quick to do it in pve if
it help you it helps somebody gets to a
quest quick or so they quickly block
some mountain people yeah
that's going to help you get the knife
or whatever black that's going to help
you do this quicker and give you some
game fly oh they
they're on the ball when it's beefy i
didn't think it was funny what was it
that came out
and they made that joke video i was like
glad or somebody made the joke video
that this is so broken it happens in
point one seconds and they were like ah
they're gonna nerf it touch it in pvp
okay yeah it came fast
oh yeah yep last point i'll make is just
um
i will as a pvp a lover of pdp one of
the thing that
always excites me is sandbox updates
when you get that
whole list and you're like okay what
guns got buff okay cool
maybe i could try 140s now or you know
what i'm saying like you just get
excited and i i
because it only happens at the beginning
of the season i remember it again in d18
lament again
but when they used to happen how excited
it was to
dust off a gun that really wasn't
effective anymore because they gave it a
little love
or they reworked it or they tweaked it
whether a whole archetype of a weapon
you know what i'm saying like i missed
that that really is exciting to me you
know saying when i play pvp and i just
wish the cadence
was faster because again there's tons of
stuff
that we want to use you know i mean that
that need love that
it's just neglected you know so that
that to me is when pvp was in a really
really good place
well speaking of i wanted to ask you
guys about this as well um
the 110's potentially getting
a look at they said the sandbox like
discussion is potentially coming
next month i think he said but he's like
i've heard whispers from our sandbox
folk on upcoming changes to 110 hand
cannons i don't know if you guys are
excited about that care or what you
think
you know what one can 110 hand cannons
need to be viable because
both of you mentioned like hand cannons
that you like using whether it be lumina
or thorn or other ones
like rose where do one tins fall for you
guys do you even use them or do you feel
like what do they need
um i don't touch one pins
and i don't even touch 140s anymore
because
there are so many just
issues with them like 110s are just not
viable when you're fighting someone with
a 150
they're just not and they're not viable
against an auto rifle they're not viable
against the pulse rifle they're not
viable
against the scout even like i like
they're like 110s are in the same spot
as scouts right now like they're both
just as neglected
in terms of not just not being viable in
the fight and
i i'm excited-ish about the change
because i hope it makes them look at
140s
because i'd really like them to reverse
the changes on 140s
um because the damage drop off right now
is just ridiculous on 140s like why am i
gonna use a 140 when i can do the same
damage to you and consistently three tap
you with a 150
it doesn't i'm also just i get like
small rant but i get very confused on
the math
like the numbers of it because i do 68
with a 150 three times to the face and
they die
i do 70s with a 140 three times to the
face and they don't always die
and i'm just kind of like why is it like
that i don't understand
i like there's so many inconsistencies
with them
and once again it's just like why would
you use anything else than that like if
you're going to use a hankin and you're
using a 150 at this point they might as
well just delete all the other archives
they completely neglected the other the
other the other classes the other rpms
like
they're just not viable you know and
they've got to do that
they've got the data right we we know
the percentage of usage of 150s right
we're all talking thorn lumina all this
stuff
clearly there's like three other
archetypes that are not getting any love
so maybe it's time
maybe it's time budget you know just to
say hey maybe we get you know up the
little you know
the time to kill i mean lower the time
to kill and stuff like that vixen
i can't think of what the uh i'm i'm
struggling what is nation of beast
oh good question what is it a 180
because i can't i think it's a 180
because i can't stand it i'm terrible
with it actually
never mind i don't never mind uh i'm bad
with 180s
that's why i think i know that one so
it's like only 180 i like is
something about 180s and me just don't
get along so
never mind i was gonna say something
about nation obese but
it's pointless now oh okay nation or
nature
of the what's the one they just brought
back for this situation
that hits like a truck that might be the
raid one
okay nation is one nature is when
nature's one eight yeah at least those
aren't like close names or anything
sorry everybody
nature is the the crucible skin looking
yeah the blue and red one that's
the red one right and the other one is
worse than last wish
okay i need to google this just to be
yeah it's the nation of the beast that
i'm talking about okay gotcha that's
wonderful 140 150
140. yeah yeah what about um
i don't know i want to see that shine
that's
my only point of view it hits like a
truck and i feel like it would
it would just be better if they focused
other other things
yeah like you have 140s you have 150s
180s and one tins and i forget who
cool guy or somebody is like and what's
the difference the range on all of them
are like
four meters maybe so when you get around
to you know getting a time to kill it's
like the sweet spot
anything that's not in you know that
proper time to kill if it's too slow
there's no point so i'm very curious
what they do for one tends to make them
viable because if it's
you know two body and one head but it
still fires a slowly versus
three head shots the skilled people like
you guys are still gonna hit the three
head shots
and it's still gonna be over and that
110 is just gonna not be fast enough so
i'm very curious to see do they take the
110s and just turn them into 140s or
what i don't know
i don't know what they're going to do
but 110s i know need some love
scout rifles desperately need some love
and i'm hoping with the you know the
adorned
that maybe snipers and pve get some love
oh the cops aren't even happy about that
one
police are in there that's okay this man
lives by like
an m like i swore a police station and a
firehouse so i don't know how you ever
get sleep so good job but
that's a fact yeah yeah
yeah that's what it is uh
well i mean i know we kind of covered
the changes with stasis which you guys
are so excited about i will be
we'll have to check in just with a tweet
when uh like two weeks later i just want
to send a tweet to you guys and you just
need to reply with an emoji
for your reaction to how stasis has been
that's that's all we need there
um it's going to be pretty short and
sweet
there will probably be way more than
emojis on my twitter
just make sure you don't have small
children in the room when you click on
the stream
yes that's fine i have it's my wife and
two dogs so no children here so we are
talking about
good dogs i don't think my dogs can read
or they're old enough at least if they
could so
evasive timbers lash i remember that
yeah but
what was there was a cursed something
first curse remember first curse
oh the other hand cannon from the face
yeah that's an exotic that i remember
listen i mean the only one i actually
had a little success was with the duke
the duke in pve i thought it was decent
but yeah i've never 110s
notoriously have been bad
you may be slower but you definitely
cannot miss they hit like a truck but
they slow
yeah it's like i always look at my duke
and i'm like oh these look like great
roles and i go in there i'm like
in theory even in somebody a good
person's hands these could be good but
no rapid hit is the only thing i
remember saving duke
but i had like a rapid hit either
rampage and it was
it was really it was really good but
yeah they i'm curious though i
like i do like the fact i know we've
been ragging on them this whole cast
but i do like the fact that um you know
they mentioned one tense that they're
looking at it you know i'm saying i just
want to see more of that you just
just lower unused archetypes you know
and then hopefully scouts you know come
on now scouts please
please posters are acting like scouts
come on like we gotta get
scout some love i got some great scout
rolls just
chilling and it's like i got the
beautiful night watch just
chilling like oh that's does great
things man i can't even use them it's
just like come on scouts i like scouts
you know shout out to the scouts out to
talaylock the good ones oh well that was
hot
mida and sidearm meta
oh yeah oh yeah what might buy the hat
now might don't you can be quiet
buy that has many dominant runs i don't
want to hear anything from buying the
body you good it's just the other scouts
we need someone shot j rabbit shout out
to what was the other one
one last oh jade rabbit momentum control
ping ping ping ping ping ping
what was that one with the body shot one
that was from um
d1 damn it was that's gonna grab it it's
body body and then boost the head
you're right but there was another one
that had this damn chat y'all know it
was a d1 exotic scout
it had like armor properties or
something when you hit somebody
bullarium
something something chat save me y'all
know what i'm talking ballooning
something so i'm gonna be something
weird you guys are making stuff
i think i know what you're talking about
at least i can picture this the d1
into my head so we'll get to it in a
minute but balloons
i don't think i used that for more than
like a couple matches or anything it
never had much love either so
i missed scouts are in a weird place
because like you might
i mean i lived on go figure for like i
saw a year and a half but
i love my go figure but as a pulse there
was not much of a point for me to use a
scout
because again it's like the way the maps
are built all the maps are built for
specific ranges so like the really they
would need to build a bigger map for
scouts or they i mean they have the
smaller ones kind of like asylum
but for scouts to actually have a place
too you need
space to work the one map that it
actually like scouts
shined every single time it used to be
my favorite map when i was a go figure
made
was um equinox if someone had a jade on
that map you were
done
well i was like we we don't want to go
too long and keep these ladies because
they get sleep and tournaments and other
things to get ready for but
man this has been a blast guys thank you
very much for coming in i feel like we
could
talk and rag on so many things uh don't
even get me started on super good advice
that is
that's a whole different discussion ah
that's that's something there really
outstanding he's been waiting oh
sanity wow teddy you missed the pizza
question we did the pizza question
pizza question everybody is good with
pineapple on pizza by the way just uh
just
just to summarize um even e even me yeah
i've actually had pepperoni and
pineapple it's kind of that sweet and
spicy it was a fun combo i did once
bacon and pineapple bacon pineapple i
could see
let's go yeah go used to be chicken
pineapple and jalapenos
okay there's like sounds good too that
sounds like a dish not a pizza
it's like is that dinner or what's
happening right now
the jagger said i can't be here anymore
teddy's like you're all wrong
on pizza hey the podcast came together
on this one we can disagree all we want
whether the titan is like you know
walking on the concrete shoes or the
floof is like choking to death
but we came together on the pineapple so
okay together we'll find out you need
some hawaiian in your life teddy need
some hawaii
all right game uh while i go do
what yeah you gotta work you guys had
um while i go do that i'm gonna let you
guys tell
and whichever order you want to go and
you guys have to figure this one out for
once
um tell them everything you got coming
up whether to find you in a tournament
or to find you
on twitch what to look for if they're
interested in scrim queens
tell them like what you guys look for
the ladies just you know
if there's things that they need to do
to kind of
you know talk get jump in there with you
if there's things that you guys look for
the floor is yours basically i have to
go knock out something so
knock out that fitness sir like how
they're fitness well i i don't worry
ladies are cool so let's start with uh
let's start with uh
foxy so where can they find you screen
creams all that good stuff
for the community i i was actually going
to ask if i could use the bathroom real
quick because i drove
down hydroflask and i'm about to explode
this is this the fitness break section
that's what man is working out with the
great form right there but you can
continue where can they find you what
you got going on
what's the good stuff all right so i am
vixen
v-i-x-i-n i stream every single day
pvp on twitch and i
currently just put in my partnership
application
so
that's awesome that's awesome yeah um
you can find me there for that um
wonderful positive content
i promise i don't rage all the time but
um i'm just finding i don't know what
said while i was gone but yeah i
i believe you on the knot range you're
usually pretty good but you have yours
too
we're grinding for partner and just
scrim queens is basically
what we've got going on right now since
she's in the bathroom i'll just i'll do
the scrum's queen's portion
um so if you are and if you are
a female or female identifying uh scrim
queens gg
on twitter will take you to the discord
and we do ladies nights we're kind of
trying to switch it up to find more eu
friendly hours
but for right now it's wednesdays get in
the discord
let us know that you want to roll get
into the rsvp
um and anything you need foxes dms my
dms
open and we're pretty active on
responding to stuff
um and i just want to reiterate that it
is an
educational introductory environment it
doesn't matter your skill
it does it's it's there for you
love what you what you two are doing you
know creating that haven and safe space
again i love the competitive nature i
think that is so cool
girls going hard right now i respected
it you know and i caught a couple of
streams
i just really think it's pretty cool
what what both of you are doing for the
community and just kind of empowering
you know
female gamers to say look let's let's
let's create this space
you know and helping each other and
getting better and and i love the
different skill levels everyone's
welcome we're not like oh we just you
know what's your kd
you know it's not one of those
situations where we we you know vipin
and velvet roping
who can come in you know i love that
aspect but uh yeah
really really cool and fox where can i
find people find you what you got going
on
um so i stream at
foxytocin with two ends that's all my
social medias um
and other than that i'm pretty much in
scrim queens
um which i don't know if vixen dropped
the socials for that so i don't want to
be repetitive okay
um but yeah so i just do pickups there a
lot
um i do have attorney tomorrow which i'm
not going to be streaming but
my fiance and chat is my teammate
lunarology
uh he is going to be streaming uh the
attorney
and then i'm an attorney next weekend
too it's a 1k
qualifier so we'll see how that goes um
but yeah other than that i'm just
excited for scrum queens mostly honestly
we have a lot of big announcements
coming say we've
got some big stuff coming up i didn't
say that but yeah
announcements any exclusives you want to
drop right now just for everything's
bubbling just
you're going to want to keep your eye on
it yes
that follow is there i'll be waiting to
see phil
enough yeah that's awesome
sorry we're just working on getting our
ladies literally
every single opportunity we can get our
hands on for them to
play um and improve so that's what the
majority of our announcements will be
about
do it do it really awesome community
needs more of it
it's great to see great to see women
coming together
and uh in destiny
this is great it's a great day i can
tell people be all day
i love it salute to y'all yeah that was
cool
shout out to all both of you and
everybody in your community for doing
what you do to try and make a welcoming
educational because there's some people
that like
hey i want to learn but i don't know how
and the fact that you guys also work
with the education the teaching the
the guidance of how to get better and
not just like hey we do these sweats and
that's all we do
i'm not that good this is not the place
for me it's like no you guys are trying
to truly
bring everybody up you know what is the
rising tides raises all boats or
whatever that bad phrase that i probably
screwed up is
um that's just really cool
i mean when it comes to you see things
on twitter go crazy you see some of the
things in this
like the world right now not being great
to have a positive beacon
like you guys out there for so much of
this community that needed
a space like you guys have provided has
been awesome to see
and only amazing things for you guys in
the future i hope to see you guys
absolutely explode to
do bigger and better things than you're
even doing now absolutely
trying to see if i can get you guys to
cry
no i was watching you guys on uh the
filler and man there was so much love
going around that uh that podcast i was
like i can't top that one so we're just
gonna let you guys talk
no any platform we get to talk about
scrum queens honestly we're super
grateful for it
so i appreciate you guys too thank you
for giving us the opportunity to come in
and share our stories and scrum queen
stories and just chat pvp for a little
bit it's been fun
yes absolutely yeah well shout out to
chat specifically as well and i mean you
guys have been chatting it's been
amazing but
the community you brought with you
tonight has been awesome so thank you
all for being out here
luna definitely um yeah sorry she's
probably gonna beat you a lot but you
know we'll see how it goes
and then vixen do not cross this woman
and especially do not wager anything
because she's gonna mop the floor with
you so
ah so that's all i think we've got but
cognito i know we can wrap this thing up
and then we are gonna go raid
another awesome lady uh of this uh group
we got we're gonna go send all of you
guys over to heather lovely so
we're gonna send all of you guys over
there to another scrim queen so hang
tight as we wrap this thing up and we'll
send over and see if we can blow her
chat up so
you know what you got you already know
lord cognito on twitter
and our iron lord podcast on youtube and
twitch every sunday is the lord's day
big sunday going on we got a lot of uh
xbox series s
news stuff going on in the gaming
console space
so check us out we will have two guests
as well we will have uh
colt eastwood and rand al thor
oh man there you go come check that we
got some heavy headers we're gonna be
talking to some
state of xbox and all type of fun stuff
and other consoles and playstation 5
on route again absolute pleasure for the
scrim queens to come
come through the campfire this is
awesome and of course
like i said to talk pvp with foxy and
vixen was
super super dope i could do this for
hours love this kind of stuff so
salute to y'all i love what you guys are
doing in the community and this was a
pleasure thank you for e
for introducing me he's he educates me
on these things
so salute to eman he's done a great job
of putting this kind of stuff together
so
that's what i got and e what you got
going on sir uh you guys know where to
find me it's ibontis
if you find ibontis and the cheetah
whether it's twitch twitter youtube you
found me you know me
um whether it's this or avengers or who
knows what i'm gonna be playing in
september
um could be a lot of anything uh i'm not
probably gonna be in the scrims in the
tournament so probably gonna be on the
pve side
if i think about that i'm gonna need
some tutelage from these two ladies
before i ever dabble into that so that
will come down the road but uh might be
like
about those trials wins can i uh you got
any backpack space over there possibly
scrim queens is open to lfg on the
there you go see yeah they are they're
welcoming it's just they have certain
days
but they're they're just an awesome
welcoming community so again
the two of you and everybody part of
swim queens um everybody in chat you
guys have been amazing tonight we're
gonna go raid heather lovely so we're
gonna wrap this thing up so don't leave
we're gonna send you guys over
but for tonight uh september 11th uh it
is one of those days in the united
states that is sometimes a reminder of a
tough thing so before we wrap this thing
up
just want to do about 30 seconds of just
silence for tonight
and just everything that happened about
19 years ago um
we all know it's one of those things so
let's just take a second
all right well to wrap this thing up
guys thank you very much chat's been
amazing y'all have been amazing
stay safe stay healthy out there for
episode 120
it has been the last word